all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 88 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we're
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got so many skipping III
more PlayStation 2 5 rumors a diskless
Xbox console and our game of war
predictions to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord who steady and continued Rises the
content creator has been an absolute
pleasure to watch not only does this
Lord consistently stay on top of the
generations in him cycle but he always
breaks things down with fantastic
technical afternoon and a balanced
viewpoint introducing that created host
of the mods gaming YouTube channel and
games Technica calm IT engineer by day
youtuber by night and the Lord of Poland
who continues to make his walk for the
next generation making his debut into
the realm of the Lord mommy
Lord much gaming how you doing sir oh
that's that's what I call an
introduction honestly I wouldn't be able
to actually come up with something like
that honestly you know I'm I'm so glad
I'm here obviously great topics great
panel Wow know one of the most
entertaining and informative at the same
time kind of podcasts I came across on
YouTube I love to watch you have lays
guys so you know I enjoy and I'm so glad
that I'm here today so yeah let's do it
much appreciate about huge fan of your
content man good to have you in the
realm we gonna have some great topic to
talk about some tech to talk about oh
I'm excited let's do it so of course we
have the Four Horsemen of gaming there
is a Ward's of the realm here at the way
down one Lord we ask that called into
the realm
work so you got to do some OT today but
you know maybe we get him later on we'll
see you'll see how that works out but of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the softer Danis mr. offline
profile Illuminati and Lord patron of
the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing good man I'm half asleep Oh
as is customary but paradise family
Thanksgiving doing that but um it's
pretty much that I'm doing good that we
had a fantastic time and I know you guys
will elaborate at medieval times Oh
glorious absolutely great I thought it
was going to be subpar yes you know they
can't tell how good it is or how bad it
is but everything was top-notch like
everything we had a great time
absolutely Gucci did as far as games you
read their stories get too far this we
got too much but uh I do have a few
anecdotes in my Red Dead recap so this
week I died a lot man a lot of because I
guess that's what happens when your
bounty
so go people are aiming to murder me and
when when you have a high pony you're
talking where from like seven to ten
bounty hunters at one time coming at you
with dogs and everything and the thing
about it is that in this game you always
get a warning on your mini-map that
they're coming from a certain direction
you'll see like the outskirts of your
mini-map get read right but sometimes
like it doesn't matter what you're doing
you could be in the middle of doing so
thing and you won't know that they're
coming for some times I'll sit down at a
camp start crafting weapons whatever
potions or whatever and then it'll be
coming for you you don't notice
so stop you in the middle of what you're
doing and then jump you and that by that
time you know and it be done because if
the dogs get you down and they thought
you're dead like these guys they come at
you the more language that I I met up
with those those white hooded
superheroes and oh man it was it was
glorious so I accidentally run to one of
their you know and initiations in the
middle of the night and so they were
around the fire right and they were I
guess the one member they're initiating
I you know whatever the initiation
encompasses like you have to light the
the cross on fire or whatever I don't
know if they were burning someone at
this thing I couldn't really tell that
that might be a thing I don't know so I
lay back because I'm like you know what
I want to see this play out see what
happens before I murder them okay so I'm
hanging out behind the tree you did
being initiated sets fire to the cross
and accidentally sets himself crisp
right so the other members start added
like oh we re oh I guess let's start
leaving I'm waiting in the wings to
glide to them I know might and um
explosive rounds so I murder all of them
save save for the leader so the leader
sort of held back so it was perfect so
he used castle the last one that I so
rather than kill him with dynamite or
explosive rounds do serve I hogtied him
and then proceeded to put him on the
back of my steed and transport him to
the tracks
where you know I proceeded to wait the
the morning train had a glorious flat
all over and the funny thing is that
once you when you call time when you put
them on mmm if you know their leg Billy
arguing with you like you'd be cursing
at you like hey so you yeah I bet so you
can you can slap him so he can knock
them out and shut him savagely myself
I'm gonna miss this this coming week but
yo solve your mic a little bit I don't
know yeah your mic is it
the connection thing maybe I don't know
you figure out if you drop in drop back
I'll see if that'll fix it yeah I'll do
that
I know Downton's and of course we had
the Incredible Hulk of this ak8 the XS
game hmm
the Lord of combat sports was a man of
his convictions the man's nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement now
you do exert first of formals I would
like to say happy birthday to Lord that
I mean I didn't expect what medieval
times were supposed to be like you see
it you know you see it like it is a joke
and you know people have fun and they
tease you and I'm not gonna lie I think
it beats your birthday last year with
the um you know you know we dressed up
or whatever you know against the monkey
bowl but this one this one will always
have a special place I mean besides the
horn and the me
and feed us and you know I must say
wenches because a lot of people were out
of line you know being rude it was rude
my guest yeah they made and serve their
maidens um and but it's like like like
something said it was top notch and for
my man you know half his birthday that
day in the be there and you know
everybody rock and I LP you know the
crowd like they were looking like it was
such a great day and I'm glad to build
that memory which you're so salute and
chairs to you the horn will be drunk in
your name you should drink is a couple
of the drinks last night right now shut
up to that black raspberry Sirocco
yes oh also I would like to tell my
daughter Leila
happy birthday today what have I been
playing with my fraud so I've been
playing God of War two it's up team
flower like really getting everything
out of the game like you know I'm like
at it you know which speedruns games and
you know doesn't do them them of the
minor minutiae hey myself like to get a
deep dive in a game and yank out every
last nickel that they owe me um and I've
been I've been just like grinding I see
how they set the game up they said
thinking about that it's a to put in
those hours is to get those grinds to
just level up certain and
material and and it's random a lot of
that stuff is random drop so you'll be
there for hours looking for a certain
material and when you give up looking
for that certain material you'll get it
I'm so like 20 times I've given up but
I've played rise and shine that's and
game Pass is a beautiful game it's a
beautiful shooter and it's it's nice and
it's funny and it and it and it plays
with itself and with the humor um what
you should do is check it out it's
inside game pass if you have game pass
if you don't remember game passes a buck
um for the new people that's drawing it
in let's get those descriptions up let's
knock that PlayStation now back to
yesterday oh it was funny I don't really
hurt me just say I play on PlayStation
as well so don't sit here run around
with Oh King like we got a shout out our
Lord vocals creaking the chatty said
good morning my lords and ladies hey
King it's my birthday also and happy
born date to your daughter so Sulu Oh
Lord fraud because the game winning on
itself actually folded its own evening
but how's that Spyro dough because I see
you talking about the fallout they had
to shut the clown's when Italian clowns
he had someone from forgotten quarters
he had some glitches experience in
alcoholic at I had no idea it was the
way it was like I think was that bad
sobs anybody see these no no it's just I
mean I think what people feared about
the game was that
people fall out is always been a
single-player experience now they're
putting it into multiplayer realm but
the thing about it is that they are
counting on people wanting to play with
each other in a game that they've never
traditionally played with each other in
so it's like you have to alter your
expectations for the experience and if
that means that the game is a little
wonky or and then you even expect from
the single-player game that's a problem
if you don't find a lot of people in the
game did you get a chance to check out
follow 76 or was it something that
didn't interest you
no not really I mean like to me
instantly I after the beta and stuff I
was like I'm not into this like I'm
actually like to be fair like I love
previous you know call of games like
three new Vegas and I actually enjoyed a
fallout 4 like actually played it in
both Xbox and PC to be honest with you
right like twice but no fallout 76 is
not really for me because I'm more into
like story driven games rather than just
like you know multiplayer I mean I like
multiplayer games but it's more to do
with you know let's I like to play you
know some shooter and that can stuff
rather than online kind of RPG games
like I even like the morrowind online
stuff I tried it for a bit but just
wasn't for you know not my cup of tea
basically I actually skipped like
fallout 76 totally and when I saw that
it rolled in the bushes when I saw that
it's running at 12:12 I was a next gen
for lower back
I heard I heard they got two more frames
on that I mean three more phrase on it
so they got it at the 15 you know what
that may be I'm not sure if or you guys
are aware but like CEO fees on PC has
actually are 15 frames per second option
right so maybe they did but they did
[Music]
themself the shinobi lore you know
sprain I realize in the realm of the ILP
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear
first off amazing birthday Wigan truly
truly want to thank all the Lords would
come out in the 10 the great beast the
world tournament we had too much fun
like digs a like and loss offset like I
didn't expect it to be that good came in
with very low expectations and like like
dick said man we had a ball drinks with
Great King trying to get me to bend me
to the Queen it was not happening don't
go there with me I'm taking my son man
Jack we're going in January they got
little things and please read the sheet
to stuff that you could do some weirdo
things that you can do in it cuz it's
about the highest dollar in that place
your coin in the palm Greeson is an
effect I didn't know I would have geared
up for this I wouldn't literally put
away at least two grand but is because
to have low Cognito on his knees because
they put you at you they got a segment
when you walk hitter to subjugate you on
your day Catania
I mean to be fair you're being knighted
way to put a nice little pillow down
these segments here with moment people
gathering up and lighting people and
peninnah me or whatever and at that
moment you can run to the back and I
guess pay for somewhere I'm looking at
them you can literally go the drinking
yo you getting soda for five dollars
sort of you just heard what I just said
it's no soda for five dollars no soda
for find out the minimum drink in me is
fifteen bucks
all right straight up just know that
part right there you plan to get saucy
get saucy before you go do like cable
guy bring you all is in this valleys the
but a lot of this is that this is a
definitely a lord space it's not a lord
of the common folk purchase the horn
chitta produce tea I should approach but
what are these I got caught up they had
a drink called the executioner and I was
just like no I was just no pawn of the
Goblin then we got in there solo to the
black and white knight to the true
knight of the realm by duty for badly
for the realm he won the tournament it
was fixed it was job T job
I don't know what's going on the night
that I chose bed
he was definitely the man if you see the
pictures I took a picture in bed at
night I told him he's a real winner I
told I'm standing I understand they told
you you know to take the job understand
don't worry about that real you know
knight of the realm
to hell with these other dudes no the
jousting was kind of late like they like
I will say this like something they are
very skilled in there like will be like
you really you can't go in there and be
like yeah I want a job no it's not like
you have to have training yeah man that
is something I wanted to see somebody
mess up I was waiting for that hire and
stuff and then the blades doing a horse
tricks a doodoo head like the Raven
flying a crow that was great how did you
train an eagle or even to do this it
wasn't a rape it was a hawk
he had a hawk okay you know Raven is a
giant crow mom so that's definitely not
going on he's not training those guys Oh
Birds bird October's can control a bowel
movements and this dude was flying
through the crowd oh hey hey all right
now okay people and then the guy
snatches the bird out the air oh it was
crazy and leave me the conditional we
had he had it swooping or every section
of the whole castle and over things like
I don't know how this man I don't know
how you trained that like that was
amazing they just add up the Merlin yeah
I think because we kept taking pictures
I'm gonna tell you straight up will we
walk through the place you know how will
you see somebody like oh my man he oh I
saw him from across the room and I said
my man is definitely about all as many
times I'm taking a picture with him kept
trying to push me I was like no I don't
care about that Queen man I said put
your mam our little banana
used me he was like you sure you don't
wanna know I don't keep up Marlene do
you read - lets go Merlin this is
definitely will be a birthday to
remember we would have fools at a party
in there and way to good fun and I
definitely would never forget this one
so salute to the Lord
kids of bloodthirsty be careful for
blood in it that's crazy so it is to the
death of like you know it's a
reenactment
now night will win and then they ask I
guess they ask the Queen if they want to
murder them the kids like to our chat
and shout out to our YouTube commenters
I like any show you have your lovers and
you have your haters sure he's a lover
hater he's just he the sake of hating
and he he got out there and made some
disparaging comments about our show
probably to the rest you guys are all
you two common chats because yeah we
definitely had so it was very upset yeah
yeah yeah just gave him debate I don't
even have to respond I looked at they
bombed 87 comments thank you for
listening and hating us please continue
to do so yeah it's beautiful
pretty much just waiting for that a
little bit that's the UM and what should
I waiting for the PC Rick should be one
more week and now be here so now that
we've gotten into what the Lord's have
been playing this week I want to start
off with Lord not
videogame system history being a gamer
and home his career my team and his
children reading the extremely
informative mods gaming YouTube channel
solo minds let's start from the
beginning well more like some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you to gave me well I mean like
I think that the first console I ever
liked by Eden was the Atari 2600 but I'm
asking with like six or seven years old
or something and the thing is like you
need to be aware that you know back back
then I mean the Pope in Poland was a
communist country right so you know it
was really difficult to get like you
know like that was a premium thing
premium device right it was not
something that you could get get and
grab from the you know store shelf
that's not abuse with you back then
there was nothing on the store shelves
in Poland right right
but let's not forget into this but the
fact that was the first thing I actually
had a chance to play it and at my
uncle's neighbor because I back then I
actually visited them quite often and I
think like the two games i remember was
river right and I think pong if I'm if
I'm not mistaken
yeah so these two but like as I said
like I played this couple of times so
that was a the first time I got exposed
to AI gaming to be right but then when I
got a little bit older and I think I
must have been like in the second grade
or something well my colleagues from
from school actually you know started
getting those computers because like
consoles back then here in Poland where
we're not really popular if anything
yeah I mean I think that the part of the
reason behind that was the fact that it
was nothing nothing there was nothing
really important as in like you couldn't
get like you know too much of
electronics and stuff right so like
consoles were not popular if I really
remember my first couple of years of
like gaming was leech their own
computers right and
about computers like Commodore 64 like
Sinclair no Sinclair's ethics lady was
something I think my very first computer
the very first gaming system at all was
actually Commodore 64 right so computer
I remember my colleagues head having
Atari 65 X key and luck next time so
these were like basically 8-bit
computers right X so I wasn't really
exposed to consoles almost it's also
like consoles like Nintendo
Entertainment System or like Sega
something I mean that that was something
very you know I didn't know that I
didn't know that these kind of systems
actually exists right and the thing is
like like so I I had a Commodore 64 so I
had that like for a year maybe two then
I actually moved on to Amiga 500 these
were these were very popular over here
huge yeah and you know amazing in
machine so and the thing is like it
actually it kind of like it made me to
some degree you know these computers
because the fact that I had computers I
actually not only gained on it I also
you know I tried a little bit of basic
programming about kind stuff I think I
think that's the way I kind of got into
IT and stuff later on in my life because
I got exposed to like technology and
stuff not only gaming but let's face it
90% of my time on Commodore 64 and any
computer I had was basically gaming
right I mean I told my I told my parents
like I need this computer for for for
education yeah I don't know I would have
to go back to my father asked him
whether he believed in me or not anyway
I guess it works because actually it
works because they bought it but they
both and then obviously you know I know
quick question because you've made a
deal what I'm
thing with the difference is that you
know from a computer standpoint it
didn't seem or it seemed like consoles
wasn't as prevalent so in your case like
your friends didn't have consoles did
everyone kind of have Commodore 64
around you was that kind of like the
norm for your friends yes yes yes yes I
mean that was that was the thing here in
Poland because like you know you could
get actually I'm not entirely sure why
that happened maybe because of the fact
that it was actually easier to kind of
to persuade somebody to buy a computer
because you could use it for something
else other than gaming too and you know
well people were were rather poor here
in Poland back then right so we didn't
really had enough a lot of money so that
kind of like you know entertainment
systems right like computers were
something that you know that you know
Xbox when Xbox 1x is a premium console
right when like Omo Commodore 64 or
Italia 65 XE back then was like super
premium pro so you know that's why I
really like on top of that around the
same time obviously I was exposed to
like games in you know I would even call
it like arcade saloons or anything like
that because you know you probably guys
had like a proper shops where proper
like places where you could like go and
you know play these video games and
stuff you know we we've back then we had
like you know basically that wasn't even
a proper gaming you know places look
somebody actually made it in Poland like
you know I think because the reason why
I say this is because the shops that we
had around with
in New York um very randomly you would
see in a grocery store my dstyle myself
oh yeah
arcade machine just a pop-up in the
grocery store as no business be in there
but you know you walk any like oh my god
they got Donkey Kong hello you put your
money inside so what was the first
arcade machine that you just like
stumble across it some part of Poland
that you had to make it your business to
get in there and to drop your quarters
inside to that arcade machine that
actually brought you back to it good
question
I think that was galaxy I'm not sure if
it was won on tour something like that
but that was galaxy for sure and I
actually spent quite a lot of money you
know playing my dedicated arcade so to
speak so like where it like was it like
a local store or well that's the thing
like back then it was more more of a
like somebody like you know like when
you have when you have when you have
those barracks or something where you're
like you've got like building guys like
moving from one place to the other to
the other after it you know when they
you know working some construction stuff
so you've got those like barracks where
they you know keep their closest and
stuff so we had similar kind of thing
like somewhere at the outskirts of the
city and this guy dodgy guy right you
know head couple of arcade like machines
he would go and okay it's what
everything was dodgy bugger my my mom
would know that if she knew that I was
going there like we've been many a dingy
arcade well in that case we had to say
oh yeah so around that time you know I
could come out of 64 then I I kind of
moved to a meager fief 500 after a while
I got into PC and actually I must have
been like you know a teenager back then
I actually even like I got into it to
the degree that actually started
building my own pcs and stuff and
selling that for money that was pretty
cool because like you know I actually
don't loved it so you know maybe that's
why I still have this kind of those
people sometimes ask me madam why do you
like Xbox I mean it has no games right
everything is on PC and stuff but the
thing is like you know like for so many
years I was into PC gaming and computers
and all kind of stuff and the thing you
like with Xbox is like it's it it offers
me options
I love options right just like you've
got you've got so much more like
flexibility on computers and stuff so
when you've got a console
I love consoles right now because I'm a
model I'm over these guys I've actually
like to like sit with their you know
controller rather than mouse and
keyboard you know and so and but the
thing is like Xbox actually offers me
like a lot of options as well right so I
actually like that V now it's not that I
am it's not like I'll be bashing other
constant stuff I've got PlayStation 4
pro as well right like you know this
kind of history I guess with PCs and
computers you know from my childhood
right
I think it kind of Ford my kind of
preference towards pcs and you know and
and that kind of stuff and actually you
know I'm one of those guys I'm one of
those Xbox guys I thought actually loved
the fact that Microsoft is actually
trying to build this one huge platform
where you can play everywhere anywhere
no matter whether that's PC Xbox I love
it I was you know when actually I was
actually you know I remember when people
actually were kind of complaining like
two or three years ago where when
Microsoft started announcing those
things that ow
right this game is going to be on PC
this is going to be play anywhere I was
like really
no way you're from so it makes you feel
more comfortable I got a question right
um being that you said that you know
Microsoft and stuff like that did you
purchase the original Xbox the first one
yeah it was you know what it I love this
machine actually you know I actually
sold it like you know because like back
then I didn't really had a lot of money
so I couldn't I keep microphone so
because in order to buy another one yeah
I hate to trade it in right but like you
know the thing is like the thing about
Xbox or OG xbox is that it's the best
console and PC at the same time you know
you can mode it you you can actually do
so much stuff on it right now it's a
it's an ultimate emulation machine right
now I mean you know there's a lot of
modes on it and stuff like and there was
a lot of months back then as well right
right so I actually you know so I pretty
much owned all Xbox is long just admit I
want to ask you another question in
reference to like the gaming scene in
Poland so um one thing I want to ask you
broke down some differences but I wanted
to that's like what about like
conventions and trade shows like
obviously you know for us in the States
we have like an ephah reeds that's like
that
now his Gamescom what was that like too
far for you was there anything polish
centric that you guys can go to to like
you know check out whatever the latest
consoles or technology was coming I mean
we can now but back then we had nothing
like that right I mean at least like
beginning of well early 90s there was
nothing like that
right I mean we had some shows but you
know the thing is like not sure if
you're aware but like on computers you
had that it's caught it was called like
demo scenes right yes
so like you had a bunch of people not
making games but they were actually
coding they were creating they were
creating graphics and music for the for
those demos right and these demos were
basically like a mixture of graphics
animation music and sometimes Tex
basically it's like it's like making a
trailer or something enough right yeah
so guys were basically making we're
making that kind of stuff and basically
you know you had we had these events
back then where people were like you
know meeting up and sharing these demos
and stuff and they had some contest you
know that was a winner and that kind of
stuff right so but we never had like
proper gaming events
well I at least are up to some point
right but there's also one more very
important thing like completely
different for like you know that's a big
difference between like poem back then
and now is that you know right now
everything is like everything is
regulated and stuff right back then it
was completely different in a sense that
you had
there was no like legislation right
piracy was a thing and nobody had a
issue you know about that no and really
like I remember when I actually when
actually had my computers and stuff you
know I was actually going like a shop a
store with electronics I like all kinds
of electronics shop and they had those
cassettes right and on a cassette you
had like 15 games at least right so
these were like collections of the best
commodore 64 games for example right and
it was all piracy right it was it but
the thing is it wasn't illegal because
it was not regulated back then right
in copyright there was no such thing as
copyrights back than in Poland right so
you know we were like swapping those
cassettes we were like you know copying
them from one from one cassette to the
other stuff that was a normal thing now
obviously not right now everything is
regulated I'm talking about like I'm
nearly 39 years old right now right so
but a lot was like 25-30 years ago right
so you know that that was the way we
were getting games like very cheap and I
guess that it kind of saved us in a
sense that that was the only way we
could actually play games because I tell
you if we were
to play like I don't know how much games
cause it goes like back then räikkönen
states $40 30 oh man I mean you're
talking about I need other games easily
oh Jesus Christ you know like nobody
would buy a game here in Poland because
like it's it I would have to double
check but you know that's probably a
couple of months kind of like you know
somebody's salary right so yeah nobody
would nobody would would be nobody would
afford it back then so no I really kind
of helped you because you were able to
experience multiple games you know at
once and that normally you might not
have you know been had access to so yeah
not like a plethora of stuff at one time
which is pretty cool mmm and you know I
actually you know it's it was a blessing
and a curse in us at the same time to
pursue paper guys like back then when I
got this cassette with 15 games I was
like okay so which one I do I try I'll
try I think it like after a while I got
the board because I didn't really get
into any of the others like properly and
I skipped over them I tried some of them
and then somebody brought me another
cassette with another glitch I was like
Jesus Christ and sometimes actually I
still have this kind of tendency to like
especially with game paths like like
your log into gave us we've got like 200
games like oh damn what did I play right
and I'll try this one
okay so 5 minutes 10 minutes 20 minutes
another one and so sometimes it's you
know I think it must have I like
sometimes negative because I know you're
going because it's funny you say that
because in New York you know shelter
self who's assisting us with access of
certain plethora of games of the system
maybe they all had no idea what you're
talking about
was that Jean
he had a booklet of what did you want to
play now he was the original game pass
so you just subscribe book of CDs of
these games and it was just right you
will get you get overwhelmed because you
would already try this and try that and
then you end up not finishing anything
yeah yeah you just have this plethora of
games and I was I've noticed that
unfortunately with the piracy scene that
was the part I didn't like it because
you did have everything but I really
never finished anything and I didn't
like about it okay so you say no it's
true I think once you like once you have
everything you don't you don't
appreciate anything about the game like
you play it for an hour and put it down
and never play it again yeah I've come
to the realization that I love console
launches for one reason and one reason
only the fresh start that you get to
start a new stack that you actually play
these games like coz when the new Xbox
came out and rise came out I played rise
to the end I played dead rising to the
end I played all these games to the end
and you know you're sitting it at one
point where you're like give me more
give me more and then I don't know what
happens but somewhere in the middle of
that cycle when it when the library is
growing you become overwhelmed you have
so many games that you don't really get
a chance to play anything and I think
this game paths and other subscription
services is going to remove that from
you of that newness of the new games
because the backlog you'll take your
backlog is going to travel with you from
now all guys like I guess we're gonna
have to find a newness in hardware but
that's what I'm just saying because I
just thought about it right now and I
say wow I just watched that one little
of me died because I was I like women
when I got the new Playstation the new
games right and I finished them to the
end like now I don't get a chance to do
that like let me try this real quick
move on hopefully it's even grab my
attention yeah so definitely like
lullabies I definitely what you're
coming from with that so that I would
say um that was during the Xbox era now
when you move up now
during the I'm assuming the 360 era did
you have it did you have a Playstation
at that point yeah I mean you know
here's the thing like you know when
PlayStation launched 90s 95 96 yes yeah
I mean I think that was around the time
when you know all these things good
finally like dealt with I mean like
piracy and stuff I would have to
double-check that the actual dates and
stuff but obviously you know people got
so used to everything and stuff you know
the piracy was still a thing for many
years after but at least that was like
like a beginning of like a legal market
an illegal gaming market and stuff and
this is actually when I think Sony was
the first actually because Sony was
present Poland already right for many
years because they were like sending
selling all kinds of electronics right
like tes you know VCRs I'm gonna yeah so
it was actually easier for them because
they had distribution kind of points
already so they started like obviously
pushing PlayStation well this is was the
that was the first time when actually
they well like you know the publicity of
it started in day like no polish my
gaming magazines and Afghan stuff so you
know I actually like introduced to the
first time when I actually got into like
console gaming was with Playstation your
original PlayStation 1 and I remember
like like I was so new to the actual
consoles and stuff that I you know yeah
I bought I bought PlayStation without
the memory card and I good yeah I got I
got I got Final Fantasy 7 right
did you know and I was like I was like
eh so I played for a couple of hours and
stuff the first time I should say I
liked it so I turned it out right and
you know think okay you know that it's
probably going to save somewhere because
I was on PC that's normal thing right
yeah and that's I had to start all over
again so obviously then you know so a
couple of days I was like playing and
fooling around knowing that you know I
can save the game so I also obviously
thought finally got the memory cards and
stuff but it was funny oh but I also had
because like when I go to PlayStation
I got like interested in those machine I
started to reading about it I think that
was around the time when actually
internet was starting being up being a
thing back then it was like nineteen
ninety six seven eight whatever right so
I actually was like you know looking
some information on on the games and
consoles so I got exposed to like a Sega
Saturn for a while I had it I had it for
a couple of months but the thing but the
problem is that there was no official
distribution of this console in games so
the games was very difficult to come by
right so I I had to sell it because like
you know I couldn't afford to have to
own a system that I wouldn't get any
games I stayed with Playstation and then
obviously I moved actually funny enough
Dreamcast dropped dropped right like I
remember I was at because you know
obviously it was still difficult to get
some of these games even popular for
PlayStation back then it was masculine
like 1999 or night or 2000 right um and
then obviously everything would you
ordering like how are you getting access
were you trying to order the game to get
a spot that you yeah expecting you know
you had certain individuals I wouldn't
even call her
these were basically people with
connections and whatever maybe I don't
know but they were they had access to
those games and stuff and what I did was
that like you had like I had like like
some couple of games and I would
actually swap so you know like with some
extra charge and stuff right so once I
once I beat the game I went I was like
you know III had to go to this guy and
you know he showed me like couple of
games and stuff so I would give him like
I don't know twenties Lotus or something
so I could like swap the games right so
leave my old games a game in and take
another one and one day I actually went
to this guy right to you know to find
some new games and stuff and he had one
of the first Dreamcast's right around
and he was actually playing an MMS MSR
so that's metropolitans
when i saw this game i was like wow i
was you know actually this is something
that I'm missing right now when you
actually see a new game these games
actually look stunning and great but you
don't have this kind of like wow effect
anymore like like like a parking place
when actually you know it's it's not
it's not the same level because like
obviously the like a spur even digital
foundry videos like the actual
technology slow is slowing down a little
bit right yeah actually keeping this
this wall yeah yeah and the bug then it
was like you know it was revolution of
the revolution of the revolution right
yes and like when I actually solved this
game but like first time I was like damn
that's wow what a graphics it is right
so I had to get one right so I sold my
playstation did you sell it to that same
guy that she was home I don't remember
but I think I think I did because like
writer on III yeah yeah
the Polish mistily so I went to this guy
obviously good dreamcast and I was like
ok so I didn't really know much about
Sega other than couple of games on
Saturn but then right and he was like ok
so he showed me SHINee's and he said
like this is a game that that you you
must play on on Dreamcast and I did I
was amazed
paint the picture located at the very
beginning actually that was at his own
house yeah we're waiting for our
consoles to be you know prepared and and
and and weed provider comes in with wait
a minute we don't need to be here right
now because like I said we like I buy
two situations waiting for this one
individual to come outside
I went knocked on the door the Rotunda
individual came out Pete saw me stuck
his hand out I put my system in his hand
he closes the door and says from behind
the door after he has my system one hour
what because bag to get its body it was
the funniest exchange that's what showed
you like our love of games
foolishness things we were willing in
danger you put yourself you put yourself
people we don't even know and we out
here you know say hustling different
right now what I'd like to do is just
press the button the game downloads
right but then back then so I I got the
Dreamcast and you know so I you know a
couple of great games obviously was you
know Shenmue 1 & 2 I finished both of
them Virtua Fighter spent with it Soul
Calibur obviously oh how beautiful
yeah one of the best games you know and
one of the cutest bit of most beautiful
games on that system back then dead or
alive as well you know I used to be more
into like fighting games I'm not anymore
right now but like back then you know I
was actually playing quite a lot of them
but like Sony advanced onic adventures
couple like Sega Rally obviously games
so I saw em I I remember the Bears Eric
I think that was a great game yeah yeah
that was a good game as well so but
obviously you know Dreamcast
didn't last long because PlayStation 2
came out you know what and that was an
interesting thing about play displays a
PlayStation because like I like back
then Poland was getting okay because we
were not a communist by you know a
country anymore but we were we were not
in European Union yet right so the the
actual taxes and those board their
payments and that can stop that was
killing us in terms of like getting any
electrons to Poland right so I remember
like to get a PlayStation 2 you had to
sell a very good specs PC right Wow and
I actually did it
I sold my
I don't but like honestly the thing is
like it I remember like it must have
been like at least like twice there I
had to pay pay like double of the double
price like of the actual retail price
right Wow
so expensive because these consoles were
coming to Poland from like from Germany
or France or okay okay so you know these
were very very because like you know
Sony Poland back then wasn't was just
starting up with this right so you still
had a lot of these dodge guys right like
anger getting those consoles for us and
stuff right because the distribution
kind of of these console were not great
was not great so it was funny I mean it
wasn't funny because like I was broke
put that money up move exchange rate was
high that was a hassle but yeah I love
PlayStation 2 and actually that was what
that's one of my favorites when our
favorite consoles ever to be honest with
you right I mean it's I mean like so
many great games like absolutely
different like I got obviously I got
exposed to Japanese RPGs on PlayStation
but then when I first when I saw the
Final Fantasy 10 I was like damn that
game so like you know obviously Gran
Turismo sport granted Gran Turismo 3 one
of my bet one of the one of the best
races and I think that I think that's my
favorite Gran Turismo ever I spend so
much so many hours on that game and I
guess after a while obviously xbox came
out and I was like on the fence with
Xbox Fateh you know I'm I'm a graphics
car so we're not
select excuse me one please and I
actually I actually you know funny
enough Eisley got a modded xbox and you
know I played ninja ninja gay the guide
and stuff and my whole family knew that
I was playing me playing ninja gaiden
because it was difficult as hell and I
was screaming but I finished it I did it
right you know a lot of our great games
have so next books and that that kind of
that that's the way I you know that the
whole you know adventure with Xbox
started and interviews with like ever
since I always I always owned PC well
some form of PC because that might have
been a laptop or whatever right not
always a gaming PC right so back then it
was more of like a gaming like a laptop
whatever then and obviously you know all
these consoles are as in like Sega was
not there anymore because obviously what
they went bankrupt very much and and you
know I had Playstations Xbox 360s
and now Xbox one and Xbox one x and
PlayStation 4 Perot so I mean I never
been a great big Nintendo guy but I did
own a Nintendo GameCube and actually
cool I still remember playing while the
Zelda the one of the water I keep
forgetting this yeah I I actually I
should beat that game I played a little
bit of Mario Kart what else was there
interesting exit and I'm not sure if you
remember this horror game that was like
you know playing with you a little bit
that was yeah that was that was great
game as well and yeah so I had out a bit
you know fun with Nintendo but for the
most part I was I was really more of our
Xbox and PlayStation guy rather than no
action PC I got I just wanna bring this
up now its rounded in and bring forth to
where you are now and like how did you
get within to the creation of the mind
game genic how did that now what is just
a natural progression of your love of
games and they're just made you kind of
gravitate towards you do you know what
it was funny to just like when during
during PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 era I
was not even on YouTube like I wasn't
even know I was actually checking you to
just from like music and stuff right I
never I never followed anyone you know I
never knew that there's somebody on
YouTube talking about gaming to be as
with you if I knew if I knew back then I
would probably follow somebody as well
but like obviously the then when Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 came out I started
like obviously googling stuff and stuff
and maybe that was a new thing that
Google actually was promoting YouTube
videos as well but like I I actually
came across couple of YouTube channels
talking about gaming right
mostly Xbox because I owned Xbox one
like pretty much almost day one and I
didn't buy PlayStation 4 up until like
Uncharted 4 release right so I was
mainly looking for informational Xbox
one and stuff and funny enough there was
a lot of like I came across a lot of
technical channels like more you know
talking about you know power of DirectX
12 and stuff of conversations yes yeah
[Music]
so you know like you know I was
listening listening to those youtubers
and you know there was a couple of them
and and obviously I was like you know
what it must be fun to like sit down and
talk about those games and stuff you
know let me try it right and the thing
is like I made a video it took
like a couple of weeks to figured out
how to do it actually because I was like
I wasn't I was doing this and you know
so I I I think I like the first video I
made like on the phone or whatever right
and made the video
you know dropped it on YouTube nobody
watched it for like three weeks and
stuff so I so I left it right because I
are you nothing about SOA SEO
optimizations and that can stop tags I
just didn't know I know I knew nothing
about it so I think after a couple of
months ago I like fine by mistake or
whatever right by coincidence I actually
opened up my youtube channel again and I
was like hmm maybe I make another video
kind of like I made one somebody watched
it and I was like hmm maybe I'll make
another one and you know I kind of like
liked it you know my quality you know of
videos was terrible but I was having fun
and you know when I actually starts it
when actually you know started it and I
saw that you know I've got interaction
for people and people were saying oh
nice video man and stuff right it's it's
worth it is fun and that's how it
started and you know after a while
because like for for some time actually
I had some issues with my youtube
channel as well Joseph was doing things
wrong and what I I think my first
channel was actually shut down by
YouTube you know I think that's how it's
at and then you know the thing is like
it was actually funny because you know
when my first YouTube channel was was
shut down while had like copies of my
previous videos yeah so what I did I I
started a new one and I just dropped all
those videos at once right I could like
or 15 and actually it actually you know
I had quite a bit of traction with those
videos because like when you are us us
us you know just like we talked just
before the show when you should make a
lot of videos that YouTube love it right
when you feed the YouTube YouTube gives
you back because listen he said earlier
that you had to have the sound he has
been so engaged with you right now yeah
so obviously you know that the channel I
then created is the one that I have
right now
that's gaming actually it was called
differently I think it was like MD Woods
whatever right but I change it it's
later on so yeah it it kind of like
rolls really you know I I love talk
about like you know more technical side
of gaming to BSU sometimes I make a
review of games sometimes I talk about
games like as in like what I think about
the game but like you know 19 percent of
my content is about obviously more
technical like it you know resolutions
framerate specs
I love rumors and leaks and the thing is
like I'm trying to mix it up with PC a
little bit because like the thing I like
with these consoles is that all things
kind of starts on PC like you know of
the architecture stuff so like even even
with those new upcoming consoles like
the
a lot of stuff is out there we kind of
pretty can pretty much predict what may
happen with those absolutely so it's not
it's you know back then when you were
when they were like making those
consoles like and they were like going
going with complete different like
something like Toshiba whatever right
they were making CPUs GPUs for those
consoles right right now they you've got
AMD Intel Nvidia and aimed well sigh AMD
but I'm making those parts for those pcs
and consoles and there's nobody else
right now exactly so they basically
mirrors it so like you said you can kind
of predict based on what's going on in
PC and I do agree to and I want to shout
you out as far as your growth on the
channel because I definitely see
tremendous growth especially like I said
your daily tech videos breaking them
latest rumors what could be true what
couldn't be true and I know the PS 5
stuff we'll get into that later on with
the top but no I really want to think is
like you've been doing a fantastic job
with that you've been killing it with
the specs and whether either proven or
debunking certain things and that's
great to see you as always it's good to
see the growth man so you keep that's
cool so keep pushing out good man don't
worry about no channel shutdowns we got
you so what'd I get into the question
that we always ask every guest here at
the roundtable so I need more mine's
your top 5 game franchises of all time
oh now it's going to be difficult okay
obviously one of my very favorites one
and not necessarily because I still love
them but it you know some of these
franchises still are geared to me
because what I went through with them
right like Final Fantasy okay even
though I still haven't played Final
Fantasy 15 because I kind of like I'm
still on the fence but like previous
games and stuff I love them
I was always waiting for another one
especially during the PlayStation and
PlayStation 2 era absolutely without the
memory card so you yeah yes that's
that's one then I mean Gran Turismo
probably I spent a lot of time with this
with this franchise as well even though
I'm more of a Forza fun right now Forza
is more appealing to me right now and
they actually make you stuff although GT
sport is not that bad anymore right I
play it and it's good now right but like
bike back it back then you know what
what they did with this franchise like
you know on playstation and then
position to both in terms of like
simulation physics and graphics they
were like the first to do stuff right
but they are not there anymore but I
hope that's going to change so we got to
should I include I was actually thinking
about this one yeah I was so happy when
I heard that they actually making
another one so I mean I guess Shenmue is
going to be another one now halo no
doubt I love halo and that's another one
I want to say Mass Effect because I love
this franchise love Mass Effect I love
it and even though Andromeda wasn't
really the best I still enjoyed it it
and you know I know that people you know
give a lot of crap for this game but
like I enjoyed I'm but obviously the
original trilogy is is great and but
like these are like five that kind of
like came to my mind right now I
he could sit down and find another one
somehow we give people the option that
when they do come back to revive if a
guy that was fantastic
he's great stocky listen to those
stories all day in and the people have
spoken to the question now the deduct I
settle from exo 18 in your opinion that
the inside Xbox fan fest show live up to
expectation the winner at 54% was the
yes tons of solid announcements and
great to do pickups group coming in at
second at 32% was the no we must demand
Microsoft improve the quality of the
show and in last place at 14% was that I
don't care crazy Larry in the white
glove segments always love bars what did
you feel about real quickly what did you
feel about the inside Xbox show okay
well okay well okay if we going to call
it XO 18 it was crap okay mmm the
problem is that you know this is the
funny thing I actually even had like
some conversation with Kyle from kiko
podcast every single with you and and he
was like hey mas y saying that I mean
it's like because basically I feel like
it was it was one of the best inside
Xbox shows it right had a bit shorter
and stuff but as an inside Xbox show it
was great it was very good show right um
because they had some announcements and
stuff you know I was actually very
excited about like you know Ninja was
the name help light coming to
I had obviously the new studio
announcements and stuff so that there
was stuff to share but but you know I
don't really understand why Microsoft
actually even tried to stick EXO 18
sticker on it because like funny now I'm
one of those guys like that if somebody
is actually referring to some older
events I will go and watch it and I did
I did watch some of those shows from
back days from back of the days right
and they were really good they had a lot
of games that the pacing was great music
it's like III it was like it was like
game after game exactly and you know
that was a end and funny enough a couple
of days before the actual show I was
like on Twitter saying that I don't I
don't have high expectations all I want
from this show is those two new studio
announcements
I want Battletoads game play I won't
crack down three obviously gameplay and
some smaller titles I want action I want
below right and I was actually expecting
some information on X cloud and you know
what and half of this stuff that we know
it that these games are coming it's not
it's not something that they keep secret
right there I mean Battletoads is
apparently going to be released in
spring of 2019 right there I'm sure the
mask himself they must have some sort of
gameplay of this game already right but
I didn't say anything about it it was
like I get that they are pushing xbox
game process stuff right but like if you
if you trying to make people to perceive
this as a new brand Xbox show for fans
of whatever not another Xbox inside
inside Xbox so like me make it worth it
right so hmm
I'm widget that that's my feeling so
it's not like it was bad as like you
know it was totally crap because it
wasn't right it was pretty good show
facing it was very
solid but like all came down to the
pacing and that was the thing that I
think a lot of people had a problem with
and it just could have been presented
better you know saying but as far as if
you look at the information on paint
from what they actually had to present
in the studio announcement there were it
was a pretty solid show just based on a
noun so I don't think inside I don't
think I'm branding it inside Xbox is
gonna go over well with the Mexican
crowd what they were trying to do they
were trying to build a moment
so by branding it a home EXO eighteen
fan fest right that pops opposed the
same inside Xbox fan fest right so that
it was a branding type of thing it was
an image type of thing yes it was the
biggest inside of Xbox that we got and I
understand you're disheartened with Asha
and I being there below not being in
battletoads not being there i need that
whole thing right there because you know
i actually played action and i thought
they would show that and tell you when
it's coming um we actually saw below and
you know then you have a back door with
that camille bodices with those guys you
look really good yeah he had a deep dive
with it he study smoke with with the
developers and stuff like that and those
games are actually playable that are
actually almost out the door should have
been highlighted more but I think that
that show was one to show the level of
engagement inside of probably their
number one audience as far as Mexico
which is Hulu that um to give back to
those fans and also to have the you know
the game pass promotion was a giant game
pass promotion to tell you that
absolutely 16 games were coming out and
in the studio's they wanted to highlight
the studio's at the end for those people
that want to know that other stuff is
coming so I can get a lot of the pacing
issues um and like Kratos said shout out
to Kratos maybe it wasn't just for us to
be honest with you that might be the
case you know saying that definitely
might be the case so we're gonna get
into it but ah yeah we got a poll option
coming out the an so stay tuned for that
so looking into these tablets your
addict is not here
gonna set it off with his topic
bombshell y'all so he is skipping next
year's e3 to ditch the traditional booth
already here cake yes a basic food that
runs the e3 they confirmed it and they
came out with a statement you just said
paints pretty much dead on you know as
the industry involves that Sony
continues to look for inventive
opportunities to engage the community
PlayStation fans mean the world to us
and we want to innovate think
differently and experiment with like
gamers
we have decided not to participate in
III 2019 we are a new and familiar ways
to engage our community in 2019 and
can't wait to share those plans with us
so that broke the internet
swegen is a lot of discussion I want to
actually start with solve on this
because um what do you mean we've got a
chance to talk me an act talked offline
I know I have think I think I know where
King stands Twitter imagine after saw
when this broke once you're feeling so
nice keeping e3 my immediate reaction
was what like right you just just hear
that and you're like wait a minute
this give me the biggest show of the
year like it doesn't make any sense and
then after a while like you stop and you
think about reasons why they possibly
would do something like this right and
it also sort of comes into light right
so my perspective on this is it
some of it has to do with hubris right
at the top of their game and come some
of it comes off like we don't need each
me any more to excite people we don't
need that audience right first of all
let's eliminate that whole narrative
that III is dying
we had 70,000 people go with it last
year the e3 is not dying and if they're
talking if the statement that they made
is true about engaging with the fans III
is III may be dying as a trade show as a
fan said trick show it is becoming the
place to go mmm
because now fans are engaged every
single year
so e3 is evolving into something
different but it's certainly not dying
and it's certainly not becoming
irrelevant so let's kill that net
already right away and this is the these
fan centric show right the fact that
they're moving away from that is weird I
understand that they're gonna understand
it they get there and now seem ps5 right
and they're good they want to get all of
their exclusives in under one roof
talking only about Playstation stuff
right but at the same time it's like I I
can see you wanting to be like a
PlayStation and apart from this we don't
need these guys let these guys fight it
out amongst themselves
that looks good to a certain extent but
you're moving it away from where the
eyes of the entire world are and and
then you're also removing a platform or
your third party and second party
development teams so there are their
third party themes that are producing
exclusive content for you all sudden
have to wait now to present the stuff in
front of just the PlayStation faithful
really right and not necessarily
everyone and that doesn't make a lot of
sense to me I think it's part hubris
part smart move to sort of focus only on
them mm-hmm I don't know how it's gonna
pan out because if you don't show me
anything apart from all the stuff you
showed me already if you're just telling
me if you're just doing this to tell me
that Ghost of Tsushima that death
stranding that Last of Us two are gonna
be like launch games for PS 5 or
whatever they're gonna be cross-gen
games and you're not really showing me
much new that's gonna blow me away then
I'm like nah it doesn't make any sense
to do this why did you go do this right
um and to be clear I think next year
they're back at e3 that would you just I
adjust my mind my question was a
Nationals like do you think as a result
of it so based on what you're saying you
feel that a lot of this is you know they
don't want to necessarily you feel there
is a little bit of hubris in it yes and
you feel that on at the same time a lot
of these things but might be cross
generational change they now ready to
show those games again until they're
kind of in conjunction with the PS 5 but
not question for you because they've
pulled out
like say not only have they pulled out
they've even they're not even doing an
off-site event right they're not even
doing a press conference around that
same time so I guess I'm just gonna read
double down on my question you saw this
do you think now they are gone from the
ESA for good well this is the thing yes
a has to find people to fill those slots
right to fill that space and that space
is very expensive so whomever they find
to fill that space whether Microsoft
taking up more space on a channel taking
up more space or whomever fits that's
that space they don't have to give that
up next year so for Sony to find space
on the show floor and exit in 2020 it's
going to be an arm and a leg for them
right it's Sony so they made they might
be able to finagle that but this this
this makes it difficult for them to ever
come back and I don't think it makes any
sense
never come back remember whomever takes
that space if it's not already Microsoft
when intend over somebody who's only
doing it for the year or maybe it's
maybe it stays empty we've seen that in
the past too that some halls have been
empty because they didn't fill the space
it could happen that way that nobody
takes up that space but if somebody does
and they're happy with with the with the
production they get out of that space
during e3 there's no guarantee they give
it up to 2020 and Sony is kind of out I
left out in the cold
is he look like yes do they say goo goo
goo with castles has a face to shine now
I mean think about it
Google Amazon these guys have plenty of
money the money is not the issue so if
they take up that space and they like
the response they get from the fans at
an event like III they're not going
anywhere so then we're something then
sony is gonna be in a parking lot so let
me get a lot of miles on this man I mean
love Oz when the news broke of our so
Nene you know 20 this was a 24 years
y'all right 24 years of them being a
fixture in a presence in the ESA at e3
but what would your initial thoughts
about this announcement more Minds I was
like what
well the thing is like the first time
when I first came across as it was still
as a rumor because I think that was
before the it was actually confirmed by
both Sony and ETA a am whatever right
and I was like I was I was super like
surprised like but has never cheated
that has never happened before I'm
president yeah honestly and I was like
actually I was a even like in in deep
shock because like it it kind of like
you know all the rumors about
PlayStation 5 and that kind of stuff
right you know I was I was I was really
one of the guys that was pretty much
sure that they will tease PlayStation
543 and stuff maybe next year or
something or where they will actually
start talking about it and stuff okay so
I was I was very surprised but like
later on obviously when the dust settles
and stuffs you know I think it is it
must have something to do with the fact
that obviously they are preparing for
PlayStation 5 and I don't know whether
they are being cheap or whatever right
maybe they just saving money for it you
know to push the whole PlayStation 5
narrative like very soon it's tough
because like you know I see a lot of
people saying that oh you know play Sony
doesn't have you know play it doesn't
have any games to show right because
they shown you know those big four title
but the thing is like Sony is not only
those you know four titles four titles
right no they've they've got so many
games like you know from a third party
like Square Enix is I think it's like
making two or three games exclusively
for them and stuff like a smaller title
site they've got little five working on
some games for them and stuff like
exclusively for Japan and stuff you know
I get that they may actually want to
show some of these games for to Japanese
audiences but like III is is a global
event right right
so everyone is actually watching right
there's some of these event like more
Japanese kind of games actually you know
make their make its way to like here to
like you know States Europe or whatever
right
so I was super I was I was very
surprised but I mean like that there's
funny enough it was like just like when
I first read it I was like wow right and
I think like 30 minutes after I actually
came across a tweet from recent era
where this guy who apparently leaked the
information yeah Sony not being at e3
here basically 30 minutes later he
leaked another information saying that
PlayStation 5 is going to be presented
to us next year right so it kind of like
obviously makes sense because so I guess
we kind of have the explanation but I'm
I'm still kind of like obviously
disappointed that Sony is not going to
be there because you know in the end of
the day that you know they Sony and and
the console space is not only about
things closes there's a third-party
content right and multiple ads and you
know they've got obviously marketing
marketing deals with other you know
publishers like you know Call of Duty I
don't know what they actually have a ton
of the mocking yeah so you know it's not
like Sony doesn't have anything to show
so I was I was very surprised okay let's
get Lord King who's been patiently
chomping get your popcorn Lord King what
did you feel once the news broke that
Sony is not appearing at e3 I dropped
down to one knee and bend the knee the
Lord and Savior Phil Spencer I dropped
down to one knee I want y'all to hear
that again I dropped down to one knee to
the Lord Savior Phil Spencer just check
this out let's check this out Oh
when Xbox started this run with the Xbox
one you know you had names like Xbox
x-bow you had all like the name flop I
think if Phil was in charge I don't
think
you know the name would have been uh
xbox one I don't think so um the man is
a strategist right so first things and
foremost he said well let's get rid of
that ugly box let's fix that ugly box up
right that's what he said right
so now we got the Xbox one and it looks
a little bit better he said okay uh
let's do something that they can't do
that they choose not to do let's put a
4k blu-ray in a box hmm all right let's
do that
all right so that not I got that so
that's something that the playstation
pro playstation folk don't do that and
any time that you see me post a 4k
exclusive it is you know that's the only
system they can do it so is it exclusive
so that's yanking a narrative dad now as
a strategist what you try to do is you
try to move in spaces that your
competitor can't move in right so you
move into the space and the next space
was power like let's move that power
narrative from PlayStation just came out
what they pro is the most powerful
system out there because it was you know
drubbing us boy they was dragging us to
these streets they're yanking us all
over the place and their Lord and Savior
Phil say yeah hold on hold on let's let
them shut up off that it plays better
over here
well you never have 4k gaming shout out
to red day 4k gaming on Xbox one X who
did that for you Phil did that for you
now let's keep this gonna get on one
knee for this cuz Phil did this and I'm
giving you Phil's roadmap but at the
same time that he's yanking a narrative
off of them like you don't got power the
next time you talk about powers gonna be
on that five hole that so a man they got
a whole leg cuz we just came out with
this Pro these dudes is rockin us in the
face all right check a boy dad so at the
same time here comes this game Pass whoa
baby who did this fill the
just for you you know what we gonna do
all our games that we do in-house game
pass what who said that Phil said that
damn Sony can't match that because
wouldn't it be hot if game a god of war
within PlayStation now gonna be hot
spider Melanson PlayStation now hell no
way in doing that we spend too much
money making these games not gonna
happen he's not getting that you can get
that in one place though but you can't
get here see this is what Phil is doing
he's strategically putting you in a
corner he's putting Baby in a corner
now check this out we went to e3 this
year Microsoft had a all site site what
what do you mean also say they say yo
why rent space in a place where
everybody's at we have our own place our
Microsoft place you can come check us
out over here plus we have some stuff
over there on the floor over there in a
Microsoft area but over here for that
true experience for that true fan love
we got that overhead hmm Sony got
dropped last year they got dragged in
the street last year you don't have
power you don't have your first party
content coming to game package or you
know or PlayStation now you got drub
because your show was lackluster last
year there was off your game your squad
yeah so now you say it man Microsoft got
they all space he doing this they got
these fans out here this fan fest is
running around they show any any bias
phil was batting a thousand so the whole
narrative is he's buying studios these
games is coming didn't come in he told
you new system is coming baby in the
corner looking at what the hell is going
on like how did this happen who is this
dude he's Phil all right so you say how
not to lose a walker he lost the war
last year and III how not to lose war
don't participate bill made you get out
the game like you out the game now you
open the door like sovereign said if
Google want to show up if Amazon want to
show up
this is how that hubris will you say my
fans are gonna accept anything I give
them I see all you phony dudes out there
talking all that crap now you know
they're gearing up man
Microsoft getting ready Microsoft is
getting ready they got a new system
coming to this who's gonna beat it
Microsoft gonna beat it you know why
they not afraid of you no more you know
why because all that stuff that Jeff was
talking before all you had was those
little games
Hashima does Daniel do Battletoads
he just said and I didn't even think
about it games are coming right when
Microsoft get on this row you know once
Phil spot to hit that stride because he
right now starting to get that speed up
the galloping speed what's this stuff to
hit that stride what are you gonna do
you gonna say oh it's gonna be more
powerful
I don't think so cuz you're not more
powerful now so filming allow you to get
that back it's a clarity he was down the
block what did you do you around the
other block strong enough silly that
still gives me a free big dead skin they
dead skin dead skin they said they have
nothing against right oh you talk about
so you're talking about what they're
scared of what marks off my present
oh no they listen brings out the III he
saw what Microsoft did on that stage
you saw Phil came out with a swagger my
dude that he didn't have he didn't have
that swagger before he came out with
this sweating like I got him I got him
now yo my last performance was very
strong I will add a very strong what was
so nice ones
III last year so what stone you gonna do
show goes on shame again okay so
basically your your again just to
clarify your position you're very brave
they are afraid because they're deaf
what a show and that they have just
those same four title show tell me a new
game that they got talking about they
come oh you know there
making games it's come dude sat on that
game you know you get the last of us
dude sat on that that game was gonna
come know what happens see when you say
I'm a disrespect leg Lord sovereign says
hmm my my the people that I have these
exclusive deals with disrespecting them
by not highlighting those games if they
chose to ride with you you know what
Phil said we're gonna be here you can
count on us and we carry plenty of love
Philter I love that do you know who won
III 2019 Michaels balls and who did that
week at a time all right so let me let
me ask you this question can I jump in
what about from this point forward on do
you think this is a one-time deal with
Sony or that they are gone from the ESA
for good it depends on how bad Phil Bash
is they for hitting it it depends
literally on how bad Phil knocks they
teeth down they throat right because you
know right now I don't care what nobody
say right now I believe competition
breeds excellence right and I believe
still sharpen still when you no longer
want to engage in combat mmm that shows
a sign of of being afraid I don't need
to take this Norma this beating does not
need to be good III don't care but you
know what what happens when the
avalanche starts like at what point does
the Evelyn you know when Sony took that
narrative from Nintendo when Crash
Bandicoot was standing out in front of
the Nintendo headquarters when split win
with Sony was about combat don't ever
forget Sony was them losses they you
disrespected us we gonna take this back
they got fat they got lazy Microsoft is
training then got then Microsoft got
dragged don't ever forget the part that
Microsoft got dragged this generation
thirty sixty was knocking teef out fill
so let's get back to the teeth market
he's knocking back the check over ugh
speed they said afraid what is a
frightening finish the Microsoft is
losing losing right now making it
doesn't make any sense
no I'm saying from oh yeah a fan
perspective why would you walk away from
the biggest fan event that's what it is
now it's a fan event doesn't make any
sense you would walk away from that this
did this regardless to what there's
gonna be more eyes on you during e3 than
at any other point I don't care if it's
your own event it's not gonna I mean if
you let me ask you this question right
what what will prevent you from buying a
PlayStation 5 them showing up and
showing the PlayStation 5 and it's like
okay all Microsoft showing up dragon YZ
dudes with a more powerful system better
service all these games and you'd like
time [ __ ] sunny would you show how many
times you won't come here with gold you
don't have anything the combinations is
wack but it the question now is that we
value information is disseminated we
know for sure they're not going to be
there lot of mods like how do you think
max over I think we're forgetting in 10
days well how do you think they can and
will they be able to capitalize on this
i I think they will actually start
teasing next generation a little bit now
I don't expect it's like I've seen some
people on Twitter saying oh so now it's
time for Microsoft to shine let's show
scarlet and all these games right but
the fact of the matter is that I think
what they may actually do is what they
did with Xbox 1x like with a with a
project Scorpio
right so like they actually bowing in
like to be honest with you they pretty
much announced scarlet already right you
know talk about like you know feel
specific on film that then he like talks
about it already right that is going to
be more powerful that is going to be
more balanced system right and but I'm
talking about like they may actually
give us a tease of what's ahead of us
right we're probably not going to hear
anything about like specs and you know
all the bits and pieces but like I I'm
sure they will actually talk about it
like a little bit now I I want to ask
you a quick follow-up to that too
do you think this is also strategic by
something there's not a lot of things
I'm hearing also for the reasoning
behind Sony's doing is that they don't
want to show their hand and that they
want Microsoft to show their hand so
that then they can try to come behind
them in one of them you know it's I
think that's I think there's something
to it because like if you even if you
look at previous evidence I mean like
with PlayStation 4 Pro for example very
shown they presented Pro like literally
a month maybe two months before it was
actually released they waited till the
very end right Wow well Xbox was
actually it was actually funny because
like Microsoft teased Scorpio even
though it was 18 months actually you
know it was the actual launch was like
18 months away they actually teased
Scorpio before Sony actually even
started talking about crawl even though
probe was actually coming at the very
same year right so I guess that my Sony
is actually like it's actually funny
because they they show games like six
years before they actually are launched
but in terms of hardware and services in
that kind stuff they are very careful
about it right
they are very like hush-hush and
everything close to the chest right so I
think there must be something to it and
well obviously we're probably moving to
the the whole PlayStation 5 talk okay
like we got like yeah but like the
actual as I said before like the the the
most recent links talks about the fact
that Sony will actually start talking
about place to survive this year but not
at e3 probably after it right okay let
me jump in Vegas this is me so I wish
I'd like to say to you because we have
some great talks offline and yeah this
is a lot of mixed emotions for me
because on this first of all-first from
a pure III stand for this is very sad
cuz to be honest like I'm concerned
about the future of III as we know it to
be honest like this is unprecedented
territory they've been there for 24
years so on even in the box you know and
I'm not having a booth I get it
rising cost of III I get that
controlling your own narrative having an
own smaller show I get that but I agree
with mines in the sense that I don't
necessarily agree that they had nothing
to show you don't think we know yes goes
to see Velasquez last of us blah blah
blah
but the big three to four we know about
that but like King like I struggle with
the fact that the third-party games that
these are exclusive you know rights to
and stuff like that marketing deals
they're not gonna be able to debut and
shine on the Sony stage because it's not
gonna exist so that part is like wow
like that that to me I want to know how
that relationship is affected and then
you know obviously before Microsoft move
to Smith there was something to be said
King that we live saw Mike for that
head-to-head likes Microsoft waiting in
his eyeball it was like it was like a
freestyle battle like those are the
moments from that you never forget and
it's just weird that they are not going
to participate like I've eaten he
shocked me you know I'm saying like the
dead not part of that so is it probably
the sign of the times maybe you know I'm
saying it may be and it may be a
situation that eventually
I agree completely with the fact that
that the space inside the Convention
Center is everybody I get that I get
that narrative about it being super
expensive in the convention center and
finding your own space outside of the
convention center but what bothers me
was weird to me is that you're still
removing EI didn't leave III EMH day
right sure they make sure that those
same eyes are still on them they're just
not in the Convention Center like it not
to cut yourself that's the thing that
troubles me the most because at the very
least I'm like okay you're not gonna
have a booth at e3 that's one thing
right but then they say you're not doing
a press conference you're not giving
your fan base no presence that is a
concern to me you know saying the shell
top actor you know he made some comment
some analysts made some comments you
know with like you said the biggest
space to not have any eyes like even
Nintendo which doesn't technically have
all this you know tremendous super super
press I mean they're bulls and stuff
like that but they have that direct
right they'll just show you my thing is
can they afford Sony to to do that
whatever reveal event is gonna be is
gonna be an auditorium is gonna be one
stage you're gonna have videos you're
gonna have execs out there show the
system talk are you gonna have mark
Cerny out there talking and that's what
it's gonna do right so that's gonna be
that's gonna be a far cheaper thing than
a whole big III production now some days
they're not having any of that it would
not support I'm talking about for their
reveal what they're gonna yeah so I can
I can understand that's gonna be a
cheaper thing than I'm doing at them
doing anything about a budget Oh
- there was just talking about compartes
naughty cutting back like your who's in
charge in charge like who's in charge of
these dudes I understand that narrative
them with 2019 to separate themselves on
rely look man we were trouncing these
guys we're doing our own thing you need
to see this you need to have your eyes
on our thing and that's fine
beyond that though no you need to be go
ahead with these guys if they do have
smoke you know what it is you know what
it is you are given benefit of the doubt
sneak attack Sony they not sneak attacks
only know these are these dudes that
were standing in front of Nintendo
headquarters talk about we got that work
these are the same dudes don't don't
backpedal now when you get smacked in
the mouth my big boy and he said what's
up now I've been lifting weights I done
took my steroids and what's really good
right now and you're able I don't worry
they're okay according to you they got
you back to the mouth right each meeting
took al and it the consistent that
element right so what about the Dugas
back hard mouth runs hole and is loading
up artillery they wouldn't do what
they've done in the past which is
announce the system in February marched
no more elaborate during e3 and MPs
actually elaborate even more that I mean
that cadence works perfectly it doesn't
make
actually something that I was actually
expecting in that that's why I was super
surprised they actually council also
wanted to bring out something real
quickly this is something that bring
harmony in the chat also I should
mention before three I mean III is
actually not only a fun fast and fun
kind of service kind of event right just
like everyone kind wait for those you
know big events and those shows and you
know a new announcement stuff but like
III actually started as a in a trade
show right so it was it was for
professional professionals only for
people who are actually there you know
for gaming industry not fans now we were
getting information from that and
obviously you know the press was invited
to play the games because it was also a
good way to kind of promote games but
like at the backstage you know all these
people developers publisher stuff we're
making deals right so I mean III is bit
different now right now because like
when did it start when they actually
starting allowing fans to come in and
play the games like two three four years
ago but like before that it was like it
was a trade show which was only flows
professionals yeah so I mean like it
also kind of maybe shows me that I mean
like Sony doesn't have any interest in
like carrying on with this because like
they don't have anything PlayStation 4
related and they are really gearing up
for PlayStation 5 but maybe they're not
ready to talk about it just yet so I
don't know it's just like weird it is
interesting and I want to transition
this into the next to the next time
because obviously it's a lot of strong
feelings about what Sony is doing and
what they might be doing in reference to
the PS 5 so Maj you had some great
videos out obviously we've seen some
things running around as far as rumors
as far as potentially 12 teraflops on
we're also hearing patents we're hearing
things about you know this potentially
touch screen controller you know that on
apparently an updated patent look filed
by Sony interact
of entertainment and again we're not
officially confirming that it's for
PlayStation 5 there was some concern
about what it might be for but the
rumors suggest that it could be that you
know and um you know we've seen a lot of
stuff going on so I'm gonna let you
leave this off lemmas you've got a lot
of informative videos on PlayStation 5
what do you think they are loading up
with spec wise and E and this whole
controller situation okay well what I
think is well obviously you know
disclaimer exactly and so basically from
what I'm hearing from the leaks and
rumors and stuff and some educated
guesses I guess well obviously you know
the on the CPU side is probably going to
be Zen based at me as in like it's not
going to be rising because rising is the
the CPU that is available for PC market
right so it's not really going to be
rising per se it's going to be based on
the same architecture but obviously
customize the stuff right so I still I
mean even though there was a leak
recently I also covered that catch the
goodness I mean this particularly leaked
I was talking about six current well
thread CPU but like even recently like
actually that there was another another
source twitch channel actually I
actually made video on that today and
that was I know actually the guy there I
mean the article actually talks about
eight core CPU early eight cores sixteen
thread CPU for both PlayStation 4 and
Xbox scarlet which would be a great
stuff but the thing is that it didn't it
would also make sense for backwards
compatibility kind of reasons and then
the way they handle games and stuff
because like you know like the thing is
the thing with consoles they are sold
like down to the metal kind of game you
know systems right that every single
thing needs to be controlled and you
know very they need to be very careful
like and if they want to make this
backwards-compatible like things like
number of course actually matter as well
it's all about distribution of workload
so it would actually make sense for them
to go with eight core CPU I'm not so
convinced on the whole multi-threading
right because it just makes the CP more
more actually more expensive just a
little bit and it's it obviously doesn't
make it like twice twice faster right
because benefit to gaming isn't
necessarily there yeah it's more it's
more for like other work clothes like
you know if you are I don't know a
graphics design or whatever right so
it's you know the benefits there are
better cause like for gaming it's it's
it's it's not that much of a difference
well maybe that's going to change in the
future you never know but like so far
it's more about like you know IPC you
know how much work one core one
particular physical color can do rather
than how many what other threads can do
right right
so so I guess we can assume that it's
going to be eight core CPU if we go with
the information we are getting from AMD
on the AP use yes there are future IP
use and stuff I mean we already seen ap
use Rison based ApS n base IP use
running it over three gigahertz right so
I guess you know three gigahertz CPU for
these consoles is not out of the realm
of possibility at the realm and I just
want to try this in conjunction with
with price points cuz Jorge is in a
chatting in a good book like do you
think you know with them gearing up and
one of the one of the main reasons I
feel that besides the miss messaging of
Marc's offered to start started the
generation one of the things that I felt
like kind of handed the platter over
them to win a gen was also the price
point and the fact that they were four
hundred dollars and we cannot understate
that like Microsoft the Xbox one launch
at 500 these guys are four hundred do
you think based on what we're hearing
about the now
based on what we're hearing about you
know the mdtech and stuff today they may
be putting it in the course like they
will be able to hit that 400 but they
you think they would still take the loss
and do it that way or based on what
we're hearing you know do you think
because the prices of our stuff should
go down you know that they you know but
they they will still charge the charge
500 like what do you think on price
point if you have to guess I mean from
what I'm hearing and I guess that would
make sense for them they're probably
going to try to aim it $400 and you know
people saying that oh that's not
possible with that kind of tech well you
know I you know do you all do you
remember what PC gamers and other guys
actually was were telling about Scorpio
that six there are options consoles $800
minimum yes right and we all remember we
all know how that end up right yeah the
problem is that you know Sony can hit 4k
$400 the problem the real question is
how because it's not only about
technology because like you can you can
use knob you can use Zen as in like rice
and CPUs and stuff it's not that
expensive and you know Navi is going to
be a consumer product coming from AMD
based on Vega a little bit right so
right the with Navi AMD on PC market
they are any at a budget gaming so
they're not making our high specs a
high-end kind of GPUs I mean not yet
right because there's other that there's
other things like infinity infinite you
know infinity fabric that will actually
allow them most likely to make like a
powerful GPUs in the future for PC
market but like you know the the latest
leak about Navi 12 talks about like
budget-friendly GPU right
and so these parts are not really going
to be that expensive right now they got
12 12 teraflops Vega right now on based
on 40 nanometers technology may may
actually be you know expensive but
that's going to change later on because
like first of all they most likely going
to produce those
chips in seven nanometers which will
reduce the cost of of these chips right
and also if you look at the PC space
right now right I mean you can get
rising based sarees and bass risin APU
with a Vega chip on it already for like
as little as $99 right and that's for
core CPU with a GPU already on them
right and that's running over three
gigahertz right so obviously that's
probably going to get even cheaper when
they actually move to seven millimeters
right so well getting our eight core CPU
for around like eighty dollars and stuff
that's not really going to be big of a
deal for them maybe even cheaper I don't
know right same with Navi right I mean
Navi is going to be literally the same
level of same kind of type of card a
budget card as Radian rx5 85 r X 480
which is which actually offers the same
level of graphics performance as Xbox
one X so you know you can you see there
that you know 400 $500 dollars twelve
teraflops teraflops consoles are more
than possible like yeah next year and
moving forward right yeah I mean you
definitely make it make sense it makes
sense and like I said what the price is
coming down and things of that nature it
definitely definitely seems doable and I
guess the last part I want to ask you
and you drop the video today and
reference it was the potential Microsoft
counter right because we know they are
also coming out with system and what
based on what your latest video was
talking about you know again with Navi
NAMD like what do you feel they will do
you know saying do you think it's a
situation we know Sony's not going to be
there you know we know Microsoft doesn't
particularly want to lose the power
inherit if it came in as an so is it a
situation where they kind of stay in
line
with what Sony's doing or you think they
even wait further until they revealed it
like what do you feel about that in
reference to detect from Microsoft mm I
mean I don't necessarily think that
Microsoft is looking at what Sony is
doing in a sense that I mean I mean if
you look at them what they've been doing
for the last couple of years they were
like they will they were always first to
announce stuff right and obviously
sometimes that did bite them in a but
unfortunately because you know sometimes
when people are not ready to you know
form for changes revolution whatever
right you know sometimes it backfires on
you and it did on Microsoft couple of
times so I don't think that Microsoft
will actually look at Sony as in you
know really operating independent of
what solito yeah I think I mean I mean
listen I'm sure that there may have they
may have some leaks about what what one
company is doing and whatever right but
I don't think that they they actually
kind of like looking at it in a sense
that oh you know we'll we'll wait for
Sony to reveal their console then we'll
make some moves because the problem is
that the whole development process or
and designing process of these ap use
and what have you that takes years
actually though I mean like if you if
you if you listen to Phil Spencer or
mark Cerny from Sony you know they are
starting working they on these new
consoles basically months after the
previous generation is is launched right
so you know they've been working on
these console for a while and the thing
like you know you're there there there's
some room for improvements and changes
right like oh like with PlayStation 4
apparently that they added additional
four gigabytes of RAM before PlayStation
4 launch right
so I mean they can do that kind of stuff
right but like you know technology and
how many cores and you know like the
base architecture you know has to be set
really like way before they start
talking with developers and start
sending them those deaf kids and stuff
because they need to have some you know
baseline to work on right because likes
you know and I mean look they later on
in the development process they can
obviously up the clocks or maybe add a
little bit of this and a little bit of
that but these are not going to be big
and architectural changes right right
like like with Xbox I don't think it's
it would be possible to actually like
change the whole memory system like few
months before so pretty much the vibe
you gave me Mama's these guys are locked
it well you know I mean good example
what may change is like with Xbox one
for example they launched with 1.6
gigahertz CPU clocks right right they
changed it to one's 1.75 after a couple
of months because they tested that Xbox
one actually can handle you know the
heating and stuff right and that's
that's that's the way it's been ever
since right so that kind of changes I
can see happening you know here and
there but not like major architectural
changes because you know that would
actually change the way developers would
have to solve it so I don't think that
that could happen right actually yes I
mean IIIi but I do believe that
Microsoft will at least try not to give
out the the power narrative and Phil
Spencer keeps talking about the fact
that they will make another most
powerful console ever right so I think
that if we actually talk about you know
I which console may be more powerful
it's I mean both companies have similar
chances and stuff right they can both
make very powerful consoles but I think
it's more it's more it's not necessarily
about what sort of specs they can bring
to the table but what at what price
price price point so if okay I gotcha
because like a good example is
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one eggs because
like it's all in the details Xbox 1x is
more expensive not only because of it it
has better tech and stuff but also more
sophisticated cooling systems right
great money as well yeah so just like
here's the funny thing if you if you for
example if if we omit clock speeds right
if you in comparison between PlayStation
4 and Xbox one X right and you look at
these specs you see eight core CPUs on
one side and the other a similar right
then we look at number of compute units
and a number of shading processors on
GPUs right and funny enough Xbox one X
has only 10% more compute units than
PlayStation 4 Pro but offers 40% more
power power why because they were able
to up the clocks to a level that
PlayStation 4 Pro wouldn't be hand would
be able to handle because of the cheap
cooling system right so you know no this
is all valid points I want to get
solving for moving to the next what Xbox
so based on what we've seen with the
patents I know if you guys can see that
with a touch screen stuff well as um
just general information about
PlayStation 5 rooms as far as the the
spec you know how do you feel about the
how they approach gearing up for the
next I mean I pretty much agree with
everything that matt said like um when
it comes to the controller in particular
um you know oftentimes you see patents
and they don't go anywhere right arm
they just sort of throwing stuff out
there making sure that no one else takes
it in case they do decide to use it um I
don't see much of a benefit to
incorporating that sort of tech in a
controller or say a unless you're really
going to incorporate your controller
heavily into your next-gen like your
stuff or whatnot what have you beyond
that I mean you know the the the
trackpad thing on the UH on the ps4 is
it's it's not great you know you can use
it for maps and things like that but
it's not intuitive it's not a button
that you can press and like sort of you
know exactly where it's going to take
you I don't think it's necessary
to have that much crazy tech um in your
controllers right so that that that
could be neither hated and maybe they
are doing something with that maybe
they're not when it comes to the systems
like I said I agree with Matt's I think
when it comes to the metal of the
systems I think both of these guys are
pretty much locked in and I think
they're pretty much on on the same on a
parallel plane when it comes to the
power of these systems like these guys
research this stuff they they know what
price point they're trying to hit and
they know what they could how they can
max out that price point right and at
the same time creating doing things for
the system to sort of separate its
identity from its competitor now like
Matt said increasing clock speeds things
like that that you can do to sort of
differentiate your system from you from
its competition on the Xbox side
obviously um what helps them is the
services that everything is gonna be
based around right where Sony doesn't
necessarily have all that stuff right
and then when you talk about um when you
talk about things like maybe maybe you
have an SSD in there things like that
again differentiate errs that can put
put your system over the other one um so
for ps5 I think when it comes down to
the middle of the system how the
system's gonna be it's gonna be run I
think they like having very simplified
UI's I think that's something that they
that over Microsoft they you know
they've been complaints that Microsoft's
you guys never run smoothly and it
I think PlayStation wise it's gonna be a
very simple UI to utilize it's just
gonna focus on well how powerful the
system is um and I think price-wise I
think they're both looking at 500 bucks
mmm I don't think I don't think this
time around again and it goes back to
being being number one being number one
and now you have now you're not
apologizing for anything anymore right
now you're just you're like you know
we're on top you're gonna eat what we
give you okay I think they're smart
enough to know they can't do the $600
thing again they can't do that right
it's gonna be five and I think they're
both gonna be five mmm okay interesting
oh yeah I'm just gonna rap King less you
got something else on the phone all
right I got anything on it at all
it's nice you know what they're gonna
come with a system yeah they gonna do
that um it's gonna be more powerful no
oh there's a fact
oh it's gonna be ten teraflops and um
yeah at the point right now right see
you're got revisionist history and um
hey Christopher talking to you baby
Christopher hi hey Cece I was sitting
there playing with you waiting for my
turn to get you y'all forgot what that
PlayStation did when they got that 360
smoke remember that remember that smoke
me jobless and run around with no
numbers yo was one guy actually sitting
in the corner baby sat in the corner you
know what Phil remembers Phil remember
the good old days with baby sat in the
corner
you know what y'all doing right now Phil
putting baby back in the corner
so all right so you have the scarlet
coming and you know you have that stream
system coming um now what they said is
yeah we have the stream system for them
broke dudes who can't you know swimming
their big waters with the sharks I feel
you I feel you I got you don't worry
about that here you say something stupid
like check this out we got a system for
you is called a 360 ain't do no
disrespectful stuff like that no you say
yo you know we got that stream joint and
um that's gonna alleviate that wallet
like that's gonna be that come in and
buy that quick purchase you know I'm
saying like if you want a fence and you
want to just test test it out before you
go big dog style you want to test it out
you're not too sure yeah we got this for
you
all right so let's put that on the table
to the side right now you said all these
causing these rumors and stuff and I
think the controller's gonna be
fantastic I really like certain aspects
of the PlayStation 4 controller now it
has a mic inside and I thought it was
really nice that when we his first
playing I talk
about this in a cop movies first playing
some of the first early PlayStation
games um
they were using that mic that Mike was
like you know like your yeah shout out
stuff like it's something to be over
there or you do something here voice
animal yeah so it was it was very nice
like remember in the early stages of the
PlayStation 3 and it had like the motion
controller he was able to fly Warhawk
stuff playstation usually has this great
tech in the controllers and for the
first couple of months that stuff works
out in games right and I really believe
that they're going to have how can I say
it
um the touch screen then is work but how
long are they gonna support it when it
sees no longer viable they really cut
you guys off and y'all don't ever fight
you don't have to say yo what happened
to that you just sit there and take it
you just told y'all no III for you so
you shouldn't they're talking all that
yeah yeah yeah you shut up no III for
you just no III for you oh but they're
gonna have no they're not gonna have no
little show for you then I'm gonna have
nothing what you won't have to do is sit
down and watch all other people party
and have you go into a club and they
said this because you have on a green
wristband you gotta put on these
earmuffs and sit in the corner with
these blinders because there's no show
for you everybody else is gonna be at
the Big Dance they won't be at the Big
Dance what is concerning is none of you
guys are in an uproar you're just
willing to eat it and take it and feel
that they are going to do something
that's going to make it better for you
later this is where hubris sets in and
they are allowed to do whatever they
want with you and you have already
allocated your bucks to take their
foolishness and that's why you will
always get what they serve you and not
get what you deserve Microsoft is going
to give you what you deserve we're
talking about right now as speculation
on the PlayStation 5 and we're going to
get to the Microsoft section
just keep it on this Playstation 5 yes I
believe it's gonna have all those cords
yes I believe that controllers gonna do
is gonna do yes I believe that Navi is
gonna do what its gonna do I do not
believe it's enough mmm so your your
thought process is that the other day
you still feel that Microsoft was going
to do whatever they can in their power
to maintain the power nap
Phil already came out Sabin I have the
most powerful system straight up he saw
your specs money coming at you he said
first they still use the mic on a
controller
he said they yah be in and taking
Microsoft nonsense all generation
waiting for them to be great again
generation money okay first of all I
didn't eat anything when Microsoft did
something wrong I called it out when I
told y'all watch Phil smoke ain't never
been wrong yet
see is a difference between when I call
mark Cerny a snake oil salesman
I call them enough for a reason and keep
watching it y'all are accident champions
don't ever forget history because you're
doing the repeated 360 smokes you and
Ted Cruz to the next level right I
believe in that cruising day lost
followers they allowed y'all to gain
gain right and in the same time the
hubris set in they were so big about
this stuff they told you stupid stuff
like yeah we got a system for you y'all
said what they said oh it's always gonna
be online and you had to do this or
don't ever forget Microsoft was in the
same position Sony's in and they made
those mistakes by taking us for granted
and us guys left and went in for
PlayStation I got a PlayStation Eye Pro
PlayStation I bought it the same time
the Xbox I think a week apart I ain't
give damn I did that but for that guy
who fell
let's treat it uh appreciate it
appreciate it and left out that guy went
and bought a Sony that guy saw it was a
hundred dollars that he didn't want to
connect he went and brought a Sony
listen they were a champ Nintendo used
to be the champ - hmm
don't ever forget that hubris takes it
to a point where you don't fall back and
you don't see it you don't see it coming
this is that part where it happens when
you say we're about our fans but we're
not going to the most fan friendly event
for our content that's like a Marvel
movie not doing no press one
it's this way there's no money there's
no mic drop like an e3 mic drop there it
just isn't all that stuff all that
PlayStation stuff is real it's coming
you're gonna get it but just just look
at what they're saying to you right now
alright so don't don't think that on my
xbox stand no fill is that dude you got
to respect greatness when it's happening
don't standings we just let it happen
but I'm here telling you like certain
moves are it palatable and it's not
going down well you guys are sitting
back saying okay yeah they're not gonna
show up but they got something coming go
with this but yeah I mean it is it is
interesting I think they are gearing up
I think um you know based on what mods
are saying I definitely think the specs
are gonna be high it'll be interesting
to see what the price point is going to
be whether it be the sweet spot under
400 if they maintain that or the five
and then obviously is gonna be
interested see what Microsoft kind of
but what we do know Lord King Microsoft
is got something with no discs in it
Lord Savior Switzer you say yo that Xbox
even though we made it smaller love this
Schlemmer you know to be nice we we take
out the disk drive for those dues that's
just doing that digital stuff right
let's lower the price on this bad boy
let's get it into more homes let's
double down on what we have already to
let people know that our content is
gonna still flow for those people that
didn't jump in that didn't engage in
that price point ready for you yet let's
take that disk drive out let's put that
there
now they're also launching a system with
this so it's gonna be a new SKU right so
the new school is gonna be a diss list
one and it's gonna have a disk drive
right now for those people that go diss
lists uh what you're gonna do in let's
say you have physical games you're gonna
take it to a Microsoft buyback and what
they're gonna do is give you a digital
code for that game that you brought in
very simple they might have like a
mail-in thing like they sends you
envelope you send it back and pop out
boom your Co pops in and you just
download your game this is called
options meds definitely said the reason
why he likes Microsoft it's because of
the versatility and the options that
they're providing you now he was talking
about old-school Microsoft you know that
DNA where they say yo you could play in
here and you had the Ethernet and you
had this and you had the hard drive and
you had all this stuff that you he said
he bought a PlayStation he didn't have a
memory card he couldn't save his stuff
but Microsoft launched with a system
with a hard drive and it was able to
save you understand so his little tiny
things like that that makes the core
gamers say wow
they're actually thinking about us so
this new system is coming not even
anything to do with Scarlett not nothing
to do with the the the xDrive system as
coming later this is just for this
generation to shore up all those other
news that's on the fence to give you a
slim ask you to remove
bad taste of all that stuff that came
before because they stunk it up in the
beginning my question is is this a
viable thing and who is it marketed to
now yeah this is intranet me jump in on
this because um obviously when this news
broke I was like wow okay we have come
full circle and I just thought about it
was it 2013 saw for the Xbox one and you
know we all know the faithful story you
know we all know that we all know about
on you know trading these games over
here there's perfect chess move by Sony
we get that and it's just so funny
because I remember and I'm on the record
and actually a solve me all of us did
almost here on the record that we were
not afraid of this digital only error we
were really at least AB speak for myself
I was to go in on that because I said to
myself the majority of my games I am
playing digitally and first of all just
real talk I'm Lorde lazy the Giga days
of me getting up and putting this game
I'm Lorde lazy I like to go through my
my UI my acts and look at all my games
and maybe switch on the fly so for me
it's a non-issue
I've always been digital digital all day
that's just how I am
now I understood for the physical guys
that was not gonna fly at that time
tremendous backlash Sony capitalized
perfect you know I get that now we come
full circle now and it looks like here
we are you know said 2019 approaching
and we're hearing news of Microsoft
giving you the option and again
keyboards option your King said of a
diskless Xbox and to me the more
important thing besides how is it gonna
be received is that our fills get enough
credit is this home this this trading
system right so conce need to talk about
a disk to digital program and right now
for my understanding is that you know
for the people who plan on buying the
discs less Xbox that if they have this
that they can go trade them in the
question is gonna be where you know I
don't see games stop getting down with
this this is me personally I don't see
best by going in and you
coming in with a million games in your
backpack okay so my vibe is probably
gonna be like a Microsoft Store kind of
thing and maybe they implement it that
way so I want to see how that is but I
do feel the process itself is very cool
to try to get people into that mindset
if they want to do it and again the key
thing I want to stress is that you know
this is an option there are people who
are like me who don't buy this I don't
go to game stuff like I love the days
that I don't have to stay online to
midnight to get a release like a
gamester I love I love that a free
download my game is going in the
background when I come home whatever
whatever I'm good to go so that's just
me solve a man time let's all jump in
imagine what you guys think about this
whole diskless Xbox in the whole disc 2
digital program the word that came to
mind is what you've been saying for me
it's the fact that they keep giving you
options and they keep they keep sliding
and all of these features that people
were nup we're about five years ago
right and they keep giving it to you in
a way which is the smart way which is
what they should have done from the
beginning is to present them as options
present them look if you don't want it
necessarily jump into this Full Tilt
immediately this is a way to ease you
into this now if the price point is what
they're talking about $100 Xbox 1s with
no physical disk drive and the ability
for you to take your physical disk so
that's what you've been playing up until
this point and trade them in and get
digital Co so you still have your games
is it is an amazing consumer friendly
option that not everybody's gonna be
willing to do and I think Microsoft has
been clear about listen this is our
ecosystem we're giving you 10 different
ways to engage with it you decide what's
best for you like if you don't want to
subsidize a system and do that and then
don't do that like we're giving you more
and more options the fact of the matter
is that they've stated very clearly
their ecosystem is is going to be fluid
from now on right you're gonna be
playing yeah you're gonna I still feel
that you're gonna be playing these
next-gen games a version of them on
older systems there will be a stop point
at some point I don't think that's right
now
on so it just gives people who don't
want to jump in Full Tilt everyone for
what a $500 system
the option to engage with this ecosystem
that gives you a lot of value across the
board at a very low price point and then
that also takes into consideration how
you've been playing up into that point
you know I want you to try something
different
nobody else is doing this it's really
and for me I think it's an ingenious way
of convincing people that have not
wanted to get into your ecosystem hey
man you have ten different avenues to
get into this you know what I want to
ask you a question before I give it to
love modulo sovereign this is some
rhetoric I'm not gonna name no name but
um there's been some rhetoric that in
these Twitter and you to streets in
reference to you guys saying I guess us
us put us in that category which is fans
of the digital revolution right they all
digital gaming future so to speak right
and I've seen comments videos to the
effect that hey you know you guys are
bending the knee and succumbing to
practices that are not consumer friendly
that we need to all be fighting for the
physical disk what say you to that Lord
Soph I say this I think people become
too attached to physical things mom I
have no assumptions that that I'm going
to die and take these games with me I'm
going to enjoy them for the duration of
my life and that is that um I understand
this the idea of not actually owning
something and just having a license to
it or whatnot right when it comes to
physical stuff when you're talking about
a physical disk drive working 15 20
years down the line and that's what the
stuff becomes shaky in it of itself like
you know you have to go search across
the world to be able to find you know
fixes and stuff for your for your
physical consoles if you want to play
these games you need these physical
disks weigh in the future so that's
that's something that for me I consider
like I'm like alright I don't want to be
doing this all these years down the line
right right now anything that I anything
that I did that I enjoyed on my Super
NES or my NES I haven't digital for me
you know in some way shape or form
alright for me I don't have that
attachment anymore
did for quite some time and I think just
like you like I'm kind of captain lazy
like I don't want to be chase I do miss
the instruction booklet days though yeah
this destruction was back in the day
with the greatest that those were they
were fantastic and moment they just
started giving you a case with nothing
in there but the game on so for me I
just I'm not attached to physical stuff
like that I understand people's
attachment I understand the logistics
behind it we're in some parts of the
world yeah you know data caps
some parts of the country like it's not
feasible it is not feasible I get that
and I think Microsoft understands that I
think Sony understands that like they
realize that they would cut out a huge
part of their market if they force you
to do that and maybe pre film this stuff
wasn't necessarily as clear maybe the
Don had different aspirations Phil
understands the value in giving people
choice moving forward but giving people
choice right Lord mods how fearful are
you of the diskless tell me but break it
from your situation in Poland like is
this something that would appeal to
polish game yeah I guess so because like
a lot of people actually well for that
kind of price obviously that would that
means more Xbox users in Poland to be
honest with you right and but he's a
thing I mean like it's it's so make
sense for my to do actually to do that
for Microsoft because like they have
Xbox game paths and for me this dis
class Xbox is litchi an Xbox game buzz
box well at the end of the day like they
are pushing those services and stuff
right and there's all kinds of I know is
talking about the fact that in couple of
a couple of years time all not by will
not be buying physical discs and any
anywhere right anyway and the thing is
that with this Xbox a it's an option yes
that's that's obviously that's obviously
true but it's okay well a couple of
months ago I was I was on of an opinion
that Xbox one or OD Xbox and Xbox one s
is going to pretty much died shortly
after Xbox score next Xbox salon tried
but like looking at the situation right
now and this export it is disc less Xbox
I'm thinking that well there's still a
future actually for this for this like
wonder powered box but hey that's still
future you know why because they a they
are they will appeal to like people that
don't have much money on like gaming
because not only actually I'm I would
love to know how much this box like is
going to go last question if it's going
to be like a hundred one hundred fifty
dollars that's not much right so for
$150 plus ten bucks a month for Xbox
game pass and to be honest if you if you
clever about buying Xbox game parts you
can actually get it cheaper right yeah
there's a lot of deals for that
promotion and what-have-you right
so for $150 you are getting into Xbox
ecosystem you're you're like you are
getting a console and and obviously over
200 games because I mean right now
expose actually offers over 200 titles
good point and you are getting you're
actually getting a lot of first party
games now obviously a lot of people will
say well there's no games on xbox anyway
right okay like you know you like it or
not like the you know SEO fees was day
one on Xbox game pass state of decay to
was day one on Xbox game pass the
vermintide to was at day one on Xbox
game past third-party content I think
there was couple of indie titles they
were known as was Olympus a spell
that Forza horizon for day one expose
gave us crackdown 3 day one on expose
game pass orientable of the wisps going
to be day one of the expose big one so
on and the thing I liked as we going to
be closing getting closer to the
next-gen and as those new studios going
to be obviously dropping their titles
that kind of cheap box is going to be
very appealing to like well well let's
face him this box is not for me right
it's probably not even for you guys
right because you're at Xbox one access
probably already right right this box
does nothing to me right but like for
somebody who just wants to play a couple
of games and not necessarily spend
hundreds of bucks own gaming well that's
a brilliant idea and like Poland for
example right you know we still
developing country right like you if if
you bring that kind of box for like 500
or 600 slot this which is $150 so to
speak right mm-hm with 200 games for
like 40 zlotys a month not a big deal
yeah so but so that's one thing another
thing is that it actually made me think
because what's his name's Brad Sam's or
sample it the actual or information yes
yeah so obviously so he leaked that but
a couple of months ago he actually
talked about the fact that there's
multiple xbox scarlett constitute yeah
and he was kind of like suggesting that
one of the one of these consoles may
actually be a streaming ball right yes
so now the question is is this this
quest Xbox is this streaming box because
there's no doubt in my mind that that
yeah that you will be able to use X
cloud on any Xbox device right right the
question is is that this sort of chip
level console that will not only play
xbox game pass the X REM Xbox game past
games
like even moving forward into the next
generation sure this console is not
powerful enough to run Xbox card games
direct you will be able to stream to
this device yeah I mean this is a good
question because you know we did hear
that and I want to shout out kids move
tough guy I was talking with him offline
and um he actually told me this too that
you know he had heard rumblings that the
Scarlet x cloud device would release
before the traditional console scarlet
and at the time I'm like really do that
you know I didn't anyway I didn't
understand logic but now as we're
hearing these rumors you know from Brad
about a distance Xbox maybe maybe like
bad to say maybe they are one in the
same right
it may be in 2019 we do get the X cloud
device and I just want to share what be
money center track because he actually
made some good points in the fact that
um as far as Microsoft Ryung to reach
markets that they're generally not
strong in right and when you bring that
price point down you know to whatever
150 $20 with a distance X Box you know
kind of thing you haven't game passing
that now we're talking about also
scarlet X cloud mobile devices these are
all markets that Microsoft generally
wouldn't be able to penetrate with a
traditional four to five hundred dollar
box you know so now and this is where I
see with King is saying with the genius
of Phil this is how you get and make
your weaknesses into strengths and you
start to to permeate that so this is
very interesting you know like like mine
said this system Chris specifically may
not be for me because yes I'm an Xbox
one ex owner but the thing like we
always say for addict it's not about you
know is that about what it applies to me
it about the rest of the world even
though something that doesn't may not
necessarily appeal to me or be heavily
used for me
there's tons of game there's tons and
tons of gamers in markets and like Marta
saying and Poland where they see that
price and they're like oh and 100 games
or whatever 200 games and Xbox you know
game pass is only a buck and then you
also throw the option that maybe we have
the streaming option you know on your 4G
phone on top of that now you're hitting
a whole demographic
not even familiar with that could really
help Microsoft in this whole you know
two billion gamers campaign thing what
do you think Hank listen Microsoft is a
global company all right and our vision
is where we are right right so we can
only see you know as far as our nose
we're not inside the boardrooms and we
don't make the choices that go along
with these companies we like to believe
we do boom um but this system like you
said it's not for me it's not even you
know what it might be for me it might be
something and I purchase from are my
kids right
alright um as a parent you start to look
at a different way in spending money
because you know you are purchasing
you're trying to get the value for your
dollar for your children right and I was
talking on the Lord sovereign about the
to DES you know the new one and he said
the price when he actually got it for
seventy one dollars for his nephew
that's a no-brainer
that is me definitely this knocking
supper uh area like you know I mean like
that's territory you can't he would
think twice about it you started
stocking stuff right but a couple of
years ago that was a major purchase now
was that was a the actual box under the
tree right so now to turn that box under
the tree
this is something that is an impulse buy
that was a hell walking past the store I
got that for you type of thing and for
somebody somebody else that becomes the
the prize under the tree they are taking
the thought out of going into the store
and they're putting it into a value like
you see if you're perceiving like that
so you're perceiving the value of the
package opposed to exactly what you're
getting a lot of times grandparents and
stuff go inside stores and they see
what's the best thing I can get to do
for the least amount of money and when
that becomes that option why be money
says trying to get those two billion
people the people that are out of the
box
aren't the core gamers we aren't the
target the target is those other people
that the consumer there are other
consumers I believe it's going to reach
them because the strategy involved like
Matt says is genius right yeah I mean
this this this is big this is big when
I'll definitely it's gonna be
interesting to see how this didn't plays
out as far as um you know is it one of
the same with the project X cloud thing
you know is it just something of a
feature that of all devices gonna be
very interesting solve I need to know if
we can rapid fire Oh TJ I mean we can we
could definitely do that cuz I was
having a whole hell of a lot right yeah
now we're not doing eSports in our line
at the major joints anxiety's at
authority hit me with his thing I just
want to get I got his votes him okay
I'm saying so I already know what evil
and I could tell you and let's just wrap
a fire just the important stuff and just
save game here for the last one and I'll
just try out it so I'm going backwards
um so I'm gonna start from best
multiplayer game mm-hmm right and the
nominees are blend up for destiny to
forsaken night monster hunter world and
see if they're right quick I'm going my
heart my head says my heart says destiny
it's probably that good win because this
was a yes yeah I'm going my heart um
yeah it's not gonna win but I'm
definitely this is a forsaken for me
looking well fortnight ok Lamont's are
we thinking about what I think or what I
would would like yeah this is what are
you what are you dick gonna win oh just
what do you want to work I think that
fortnight going to it I'm going with the
crowd and fortnight looking at Attica
chases
he's got fortnight alright
alright next category is best sports
slash racing game Oh
the nominees are FIFA 19 or the horizon
for Mario Tennis Aces NBA 2k 19 and Pro
Evolution Soccer 2019 all right I think
force is just gonna smash this Forza
horizon for and I believe um addict also
has forces so those are folks yep I'm
force as well although I mean that those
FIFA games they have worldwide appeal
but I for the hordes of my honor
absolutely Forza was a king best
strategy game banner saga 3 mm
Battletech Punk into the preach Valkyria
Chronicles for okay I'm going my heart I
love banner saga I think the series is
fantastic and will abandon saga 3 and
for addict I have his vote is he's going
with Battletech so those are two votes I
have to go with into the breach to the
breach to the breach is gonna clean
house here yeah okay alright are we
doing best family game vote for a
doctoral II so we might not be able to
do it because yeah we don't have a vote
won't be fair okay so let's do family
okay next one best fighting game alright
new nominees are blaze blue cross tag
battle Dragonball Fighters Soul Calibur
6 and Street Fighter 5 RK
addition mmm I'm going with that Soul
Calibur baby I'm going with that so
Calibos six addicts vote is Dragon Ball
Dragon Ball fighters II yeah i don't
find like the way this is feeling
alright we move on to best RPG right we
have dragon quest 11 echoes of an
elusive age we have monster hunter world
ninokuni two revenant kingdom hmm
hostile path traveller and pillars of
eternity two dead fire whoo man this is
tough um I struggle because they have
mastered world hunter world in here
uh-huh my heart says octopus or nuni but
I think master hunters gonna witness me
I'm gonna go I'm a pig my solitaire um
addict has pillars of eternity yep I
agree with addict I don't think they'll
win that game is just too good I will go
with octopus traveler I'm gonna go with
me no mmm okay we got alrighty next
category best action-adventure game mmm
have a sea Odyssey oh god of war
Marvel's spider-man Red Dead Redemption
- and shadow of the Tomb Raider damn
this is soft all right this is easy all
[Applause]
right I would like to give other games
their shine in other categories but it's
gotta be ready
i'ma go against the grain I'm against
the green um I feel that Red Dead is
gonna
up in so many other categories um cuz
you got got a war in here Assassin's
Creed combat mm I don't know if I'm
giving this a screed on combat
so basically mob it comes down to me god
dissing red there but it come down to me
between spar war and I think you gotta
gotta give it to God walk combat like
action-adventure combining combat with
nobody say with Traverse I'm spider-man
got traversal and puzzles but this is
tough
spider-man traversals I mean that is
right I would keep it a buck I think
this is the only category spider-man's a
shot at winning
I know King gonna be mad with me but I
think I'm gonna go with Spidey on this
one this is where I think Spidey comes
through an addict he has assassins
alright things get blurry after that
because got a wolf okay okay so next one
is just best action game right and then
this is for the best game of the action
genre focused on combat so the nominees
are Call of Duty 4 black and call duty
black ops 4 mm-hmm dead cells mmm yes
the need to Forsaken oh let's go Far Cry
5 mmm
make a man 11 mmm okay action
tough oh man this is tough we got a we
got dead cells in there that's a tough
one you know my heart is that desk I
think this the only shot that's been
done winning any over because fortnight
is not in there one sport night in the
building and not winning so this is the
one I'm going my heart but I actually
think they got a shot so I'm going with
that's the attic for action Oh attics
one with destiny also so he's got him on
destiny what about the rest of you Lords
somehow I feel like blood cups for has a
chance yeah it's a good game in playing
[ __ ] out more good solvent King dead
cells for me
go with the best VRA our game you know
he don't like Vyasa I don't think he
voted on that yeah he didn't skip that
one cuz we gotta have a consensus yeah
okay did he vote on best mobile game no
no you know etiquette mmm
next one best independent game yes voted
on that okay great so the nominees for
best indie game are Celeste that's my
heart my heart into the breeze honest my
heart the turn of the obrah den I've
heard a lot about this game the last
once and I haven't touched it I have no
idea what it is and of course the
messenger that is also look at you said
best India I'm looking at best debut in
the give me I'm giving them choices one
more time four best Brittany Celeste
mm-hmm hmm into the breach return of the
oh burden and the messenger okay I look
at it i scope okay this is tough so less
is probably gonna win cuz it's in the
game of the Year category I believe it
it's not gonna win game yeah but even
though it's a great mention my heart is
the messenger but I the message is not
gonna win as much as I love that game
it's not gonna win Dan Ted cells is
tough though that's a good one to UM
whoa it's the breach I've heard yeah I'm
gonna go with this is Celeste winning
I'm gonna play logic now I think Celeste
is gonna take this one surprisingly
addict has my game he has the messenger
yeah yeah I'm shocked by that cuz he was
giving me so much crap when we have
packs and I was covering it what do you
guys got what it wrestler got I got
Celeste Oh
that's the last time this is the police
to year that's about writing right all
right on games for impact
oh I believe he did yes he did okay um I
haven't played a lot of these but okay
eleven eleven memories retold I'm
Celeste mmm
Florence life is strange - episode one
and the last game is missing
JJ Mack field and the island of memories
whoa
a lot of these games I have not played
so there's gonna be tough I'm just gonna
go with my bias pick based on history
which is I've heard good things about
the new one which is life is strange so
I'm gonna go a life strange to donat
they always dock it out with the fields
I'm going this addict hey I had a guy's
life Israelis do as well
Celeste again that story is kind of
amazing for such a small tiny little
game it's great to see that yes
Celeste life is strange sir I'll take
that so best performance yes he did it
okay Brian
eh are they sharp as Connor and Detroit
become human wow he's big christopher
Judge
as Kratos God of War boy MELAS aunty
mahute as Cassandra she should have been
the only character in that game he shot
fine I heard that Wow
Rajan Clark as Arthur Morgan ready
and Yuri Lowenthal as Peter Parker
Barbeau spider-man but first of all
everybody could win this
really everybody could win this like
this is may this is just most
competitive probably my opinion let's do
process of elimination I love Detroit
but my Manny go win
now here's where get interesting
Yuri did his thing and Peter Parker but
I don't I think it comes down to the
final three I think God of War dude you
know how he get down but did he kind of
limited with his boys I don't know
i'ma probably go between author Roger
Clark for us Arthur Morgan now I heard
amazing things about Cassandra an
amazing SS is creep it's gonna get it
down at these two the popular pick is
definitely author Morgan there's no
doubt if assasin screens gonna win I
think this is the shot I'm gonna go with
Cassandra I'm home girl I think I think
read dad's gonna do its thing and
remember it's not only voice acting it's
the motion and performance capture as
well so when you talk about Kratos
Kratos like there was a lot of emotional
quiet moments yeah he was just boiling
it up and be like I can't give him
performance on that all the market could
win this like it's no doubt like art was
one of the best characters it's tough
I might regret this is probably gonna be
it could probably gonna be awesome
Morgan but I'm gonna go with Cassandra
cuz again from everything I've seen from
everything from people I trust on that
game they said her performance is
outstanding I saw some stuff from attic
when I was watching that that I was like
yeah so I'm going I'm going there on
addict has read that he has awesome
organ that's his choice as well no
character bogan mmhmm yeah I'll go with
red dead says oh okay well we go boy I'm
going with God a war boy
you know they probably all the Morgan
probably says boy a lot more than all
right so did he do best audio design
best ODU I believe yes he did did oh
great I'm sorry Miko this is it call of
duty black ops for mm-hmm or is the
horizon for God of War Marvel spider-man
mm-hmm Red Dead Redemption
- hi first off the fact that I know
destiny is sacrilegious I'm tired of
destiny getting disrespected or audio
every game award I am sick of this crap
but I got a vote one wasn't left the use
of audio I think red Dead's use of audio
is really a me I can't remember anything
spectacular it's just it yeah Red Dead
is just the nature sounds weird swells
and goes down like in everything
everything looks surprisingly red
there's no win this after i got red
there on our own audio a now it looks
like addict as well okay did he do best
score yes he did okay so best score the
last god of war mmm marvel spiderman mmm
ninokuni - mmm
not the path traveller it's musical
score I'm gonna take this while I'm at
safely on the ninokuni Yamuna
and then played the path outstanding
from Houston like playing out it was
okay
normal spotty i'ma go with Celeste them
go Celeste here just I would have picked
my [ __ ] in place I can't honestly pick
somebody play so yeah I'm going Celeste
looks like a dick welcome Celeste mm-hmm
we do best art direction all right it's
for outstanding creative and/or
technical achievement and artistic
design and animation the nominees are AC
Odyssey God of War octave path traveller
read dead 2 return of a burden
achievement in artistic design and
animation he's gotta go down to the
heavyweights man I think it's gotta go
down to the God of War in the arm and
the red dead and I just I got to read
that character one time creative and
technical achievement and artistic
design animation mm-hmm
animation of God was pretty tough man
pretty tight stuff it this is really a
pick'em it's really what you view as
beautiful work you know I might I might
go a god wall because it read the
animations are slow realistic in a way
that no one else does yeah I know I do I
do but good of war is more flashy and
stuff yeah
God was more popping like it's about
poppy
gage so i'ma go guard already but I mean
I could see this going addict has
Assassin's Creed okay I have I have read
that I think the hardest thing to do is
mimic reality alright next category Best
narrative hmm and that goes let me see
we have Detroit become human we have
that of war
we have life a strange episode to
episode cipher strange - episode 1 sorry
Marvel's spider-man Red Dead Redemption
- I feel sad for Detroit because
technically this is the category should
be winning but it's gonna come down to
Red Dead on this road I think it's gonna
have to cuz we're just doing such true
or just doing too much it's a mature
level story you know yeah I might have
to go a Red Dead on this surprisingly a
Takei's Detroit I'm shocked Wow longer
I'm gonna read that I'm nowhere near
finishing that game but I heard amazing
things about the ending so generally
that's game direction oh I don't see it
I don't see it no yes yes he did all
right best game direction a way out
King's gonna have a chuckle about that
one a way out took a way out and finish
it
we come here with God of War Marvel's
spider-man and Red Dead Redemption -
right
tough o direction what does that mean
though what are they saying they say I
said awarded to a game studio for
outstanding creative vision and
innovation in game direction and design
probably gonna be Red Dead here I'm
gonna vote with my heart though cuz I'm
a Detroit sucker and I think the Tri
gotta win something but I think probably
not but yeah I'm going to try here Alex
won't work for what's up yeah what's
that it going with Alex going with a way
out I agree I agree it's something I was
just unique it's just very unique no
I'll go with best ongoing game yeah I
got that too
okay so nominees destiny - forsaken oh
[Laughter]
no man sky
overwatch and Rainbow six siege my heart
for sale for sake it's not winning it's
for tonight's winning it's in the land
slow it's not even close
um I feel a dick though he's got um he's
got siege see and she should win siege
is the game that should win but for what
that's gonna win but I think I see what
he's doing
yeah I agree for today he's gonna win
mm-hmm sadly and okay are we missing
anybody on this one mass did you vote no
I said for tonight okay King for tonight
okay my category game of the year who
the nominees are Assassin's Creed
Odyssey the last isolettes be in there
that's good god of war
Marvel's spider-man Monster Hunter world
I'm feeling to be there too and Red Dead
Redemption to let's go
you know my bow I'm gonna put up Spidey
I'm a vote with my heart I lost last
year by voting with my heart I'm gonna
vote with what everybody gave me the
most flack that I've got on Twitter for
the win but away you go with the boy for
the win it's not a bad choice man I
would just say off top
sorry so less than that one in this
fight now in this master huh no more
than that one it's this town that
heavyweights it's just a heavyweight
battle right now it's gonna be red the
red that just came through like a
whirlwind man they just came through
like a whirlwind in art but I think it
could be got Awards just because with
red dead people had overall more
negative things to say about it
then they got a war I think it could be
got a war but I'm still rolling my heart
red I hate I just didn't think it would
sneak through the back door and just
generate I thought it would be too late
in the cycle that God of War had it
dominated but that's just me addict has
oh my yeah red dead
alright so that's it with the recent
announcement of Saudi that attending or
holding an offset off-site press
conference during e3 is this a mistake
by Sony to skip on gaming's largest
event of the year the choices are a yes
Sony skipping III is a promotional
misstep and breeds arrogance no III is
overrated
and someone can gear up for ps5 as the
market leader
see I don't care ghost you see my fruit
man is the real loser here I'll be vote
when it goes up Lord mods gaming an
absolute pleasure to have around with
the Lord's great perspective from
overseas we learned a lot especially how
you got those systems that was quite
humorous we're kidding the five people
find you and what you have going on is
he still assisting us mic is muted his
mic is muted he's mine he's so excited
to mute his mic
Bob can you hear us everybody come back
Lord
solve we can find you they can find me
under a palm tree this coming week
chillin on Twitter Lord Sai Opie and PSN
Xbox Live be exuberant guys have a great
Thanksgiving with your family friends
and so they have a lot of food play a
lot of games and be safe Lord mods thank
you for coming through it's always great
to get perspectives on gamers from
around the world because everybody's
experience is so different and it's just
amazing that we always come back to the
same thing that we always circle back to
the same thing and that's fantastic well
thank you so much for being here
although Marcus back man like absolute
pleasure to have you in Rome and Rick
and the fact people find you what do you
have going on sir well YouTube obviously
mods gaming so check check it out on
YouTube I mean like I'm honestly focused
on more technical side of things
obviously so if you into into specs and
4k gaming well check my next G no mods
yes oh and then obviously on Twitter so
that's at MMD woods underscored Twi
Billy nice if I'm if my memory serves me
right so yeah thank you very much for
inviting me for the unite salute pledge
I had a blast I love your podcast and
stuff Thank You Lauren the way you
handle game the EV of it so thanks for
having me me you definitely have you
back in the future as well a pleasure
Lord Mart in the round
the Lord of Poland in next-generation
gaming but yeah bad so a lord king we
can find imagine first of all first and
foremost shout out to the Polish Pusha T
you know gaming all over the world and I
love that whole thought about it that he
was doing going to shady people to get
games just like he was doing in New York
I think it's crazy it's bigs man
it's been over cyl everybody's
experiences and this this that goes to
show you again and I'm gonna keep saying
it every time we have a new guest from a
different place and they're doing the
same thing that you're doing you're not
different than the person next to you
you have the same love affair and it's
just gaming thing and it keeps us bonded
and tied to each other so the in
fighting about what system is better
it's stupid because it's just it boils
down to gaming alright so um you can
find me on Instagram Twitter uh
the Facebook community I'm in there
retweeting most of cog needles busy
business you know we're posting pictures
and you're gonna catch me at medieval
times oh you can catch me we're like
Microsoft caring up for III watch us
play watches dance
obviously Abdullah Ahmad came through
and Lord annek you would definitely miss
so we hopefully get him back in the
realm
next up later please hit that like to
subscribe to all the outlets Nouriel
kabocha shall becoming Spotify iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play the links will be
in the
Crypton all that helps us out big-time
shout to Lourdes narro in the screen
team ya review coming up and also our
guy Lord potential perfect she'll be
having an article dropping soon and I
can't say any website in just yet
because he's gonna kill me we got some
things come and we got some things on
apartment we definitely appreciate the
support
Youngblood lon MJ got sting cooking as
well please make sure you still sign up
ILP Smash Brothers giveaway and that ILP
patreon we got a lot of give all things
together give out myself can I do it
unless you grease his bombs and get in
the patient exactly flashpoint number
forty with my man eat this was a bang
yeah
the legendary Rick cactus HD he was in
the building special time on Saturday
talking everything about running
fighting back against Activision all the
latest with the black only DLC please
check that up that is already up on the
ILP YouTube channel and I know Kings
that combat talk cooking
I see arrows mention some people talking
so I know he's comfortable always height
would be money was on me so good
anybody's got anything else you're
sending me out of here please